like this
she's Brave she puts some together
so there's no voting okay or do we have
good morning
call house finance committee to order
we're here for a public hearing on a
non-germaine amendment I would like to
welcome Chuck grassy our new member
through the finance committee
um
and I will um
call on representative J.R Hull to
introduce amendment number zero seven
thank you Mr chair
to introduce as you just said
two zero two three zero seven six seven
eight I'm going to be looking at both
the amendment and then there's a
side-by-side comparison between this and
an amendment that division three had
worked on prior that was the foundation
um
in the original Amendment which was 804
we were looking at six to twelve beds
this plan is an operate 12 beds only
um it makes and the reason that this is
a non-germaine amendment is on page two
of the comparison it has to do with a
bill that was adopted by the prior
Legislature House Bill 254
out of the house but I don't think
became law relative to who could be
committed to
the sununu center and this is where it
starts to change from the current list
of people and the various crimes that
they could be committed under to the
most serious of crimes right all all the
all the crimes against a person that are
significant murder or sexual assault all
of those type crimes and not all the
ones that are currently things that
would be a Class A misdemeanor because
of stealing an iPad right the the value
of goods has changed so significantly
over time and we haven't kept up with
the laws that potentially you could
incarcerate kids for
um very serious crimes but very serious
being defined by the value of an item
and there is at least some information
that has been presented to the committee
that incarcerating youth under those
conditions actually causes more harm in
the long term it doesn't help them
rehabilitate so if we limit the number
of crimes that people are going to the
Student News Center we can keep the
population lower down into 12 beds
um with that I'll close my testimony
unless there's any other questions
thank thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative hole are you aware that
both the chair and vice chair of
Children and Family Law have HB 120
retained in their committee and uh they
have uh they they would be here except
for their an exec session right now
voting but they have both told me that
they would prefer that any changes to
the criminal statutes be sent to them
because they've not had an opportunity
to hear it this term and they think it's
more appropriate for their jurisdiction
than the finance committee have you
heard that
thank you chairman Edwards yes I have
um and
we're dealing with the finance side
we're not a policy committee
the current cost
um
we're looking at like 87 I think the
budget request was 87 people for the
roughly 12 on average children that are
in the sununu center
we're looking at an operating budget
that's somewhere between 10 and 12
million dollars right so this is our
incarceration costs are somewhere
between 800 000 and a million dollars
per child
we should be looking at what is the
appropriate list to put in the center
given the extraordinarily high cost for
incarceration of Youth
um and that was talked about in in this
amendment in particular regarding
Staffing ratios and designing a building
that long term would be set up and and
strategically to have lower Staffing
ratios I mean having 87 people
for roughly 12 children on average is
almost eight staff members per child
that's that's a huge number so I think
there may be a way long term to keep the
cost in line but yes to your point to
your question exactly I that policy
question was historically won by
children and family law but it might
need to be taken up this time around
here because of the impact on right the
the total cost of the facility for both
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
Hull
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee when I when I signed up to to
testify on this bill you know on the
signed a pink card it said uh
um do you support or do you oppose and I
was really and in a quandary about
exactly what to say because I very
strongly support the overall thrust of
this bill to close the sununu center and
build a new facility and and build it in
accordance with uh you know the terms
that are set set out in the uh in the uh
in the bill
um
I I have concerns about the what I would
refer to as the 254 aspect of it that's
the bill number from last year that
purports to change the
um the crimes for which a person can be
committed
um and I guess I would say I've had
extensive discussions with with
representative erf and representative
Edwards about this and I think that the
proposal as it is reflected in the
amendment that was just referred to by
representative Hull
uh I'm I I'm all right with that I think
I think that that
um you know that uh
is is okay in the sense that it it my
main concern last year and this year has
been that
um the there was a prior version that
did not that would have excluded
any potential for someone being
committed for serious property crimes no
matter how serious and so the example
that you know that what I what the
example I've used before and I think
really would highlight this is if
someone if a if a juvenile even a
juvenile with a serious prior record
were to were to come in and you know
burglarize your home when you weren't
there so there was no danger of physical
you know of physical harm but literally
clean out your home destroy it
um uh unless you unless the the terms
that were included in the most recent
amendment that representative oh uh
proposed there would be no possibility
of a juvenile being able to be committed
for even one day and it just seems to me
that that doesn't make sense
so I I guess what I bottom line is I I
think the proposed amendment is is sort
of acceptable
with one caveat and that is that and
I've talked to representative erf about
this and I've actually submitted a
proposed amendment which I think maybe
representative Edwards may talk about at
some point
um
right now
the the the proposal
allows for commitments of juveniles
for certain offenses that are specified
in
section 169 B
um uh uh 19 1 J and 1M
in order to have the bill make sense
you need to make a similar change in in
terms of what for what offenses can
somebody be detained
but unfortunately that that is not in
the bill right now it is in my Amendment
uh I think my amendment is eight number
eight ninety two but if you don't make
that change
you would you could literally have a
situation I think and this to me just
sounds crazy it doesn't make any sense
you could literally have a situation
where a juvenile is arrested for a very
serious property crime or maybe even
some other crime that's that's very
serious but is not among the the ones
that are that are listed
um in J and you could have a situation
where everybody knows from the outset
that this is an offense that that merits
the the child is going to get some
period of commitment at uh at a secure
facility and yet the judge has no power
as a matter of law would be precluded
from detaining the child so I mean you
know I I mean literally I I this is so
maybe I I'm I'm making up a you know
sort of an absurd situation but
literally under the law this would apply
you could have that situation like that
I gave the example of the judge of the
person trashing the house when you're
not home the person could literally be
charged with uh uh under subsection M
come into court for the preliminary
hearing and tell the judge you know
listen judge I'm not going to show up
what are you going to do about it and
the answer the judge would the judge
would have to say nothing because the
law if you don't make the change that
I've suggested the law would be sorry
even though everybody knows that this is
a very serious crime a very serious
juvenile offense that the person might
uh be committed for or would be
committed for you you have to let the
person there you you could not impose A
A detention you can impose some other
things but you can't impose detention
which to me doesn't doesn't make sense
um the last point I would make and I
have to say honestly I had not thought
about this but I hope you'll pay
really careful attention to what
director ribsom has to say because he
raises a very good point about
um the uh the situation of changing the
law from what it is now to remove things
which the which the both my Amendment
and representative wolves remember do to
remove simple assault from the offenses
that that are potentially the basis for
detention or commitment and he gives
really good examples of sometimes there
are situation not very often doesn't
happen often but sometimes there can be
situations and I think he gave the
example of a child that assaults his
parents and the child doesn't there
aren't any other family members
available or there's no there isn't
foster care or whatever available and If
you if the if the law is that even that
in those circumstances the the uh the
the court can't commit the juvenile to a
secure facility even for a few days
um but then what happens I mean what are
you going to do in that kind of
situation is the the juvenile can't go
home
um so it's it just seems to me that that
to make the law so strict that it
doesn't have the flexibility to
accommodate that I think is is really
problematic and I guess then the last
thing that I would say is is this
I think there's much to representative
uh Edward's point about this uh this
aspect of this bill not having gone to
the policy committee uh for review
and I would also note I I just I I think
it's important to note this it seems to
me getting the sununu center done the
new sunun said done is is crucial it's
got to be a number one priority
and I think that injecting this aspect
into this
puts that at least to some extent at
risk uh because they're I I my
impression is that the Senate may not
have the same view
about this 254 aspect of this
um as as these proposed amendments do
um and and why raise why
why raise that issue why not have that
just as a separate matter get the sununu
Center built a new one done and and and
then deal with this as a separate issue
that would be my my uh my suggestion but
uh anyway thank you that's all I have to
say
questions from any Committee Member
representative Edwards and then
representative McGuire uh thank you uh
Mr chair I I think there's a couple
three questions I'd like to ask
representative Lynn that are all related
to one another
um I I'm a little confused by your
testimony sir I I at one point I thought
I heard you say that you support uh
Amendment zero seven six seven and then
as you continue to talk it sounded to me
like you weren't really in support
because you had concerns about how
simple assault and property crimes might
be treated and so I I just want to make
sure I'm clear on what your position is
if is it yes or no on zero seven six
seven so I get I mean I guess I guess
what I would what I meant to say is zero
seven six seven I think is an
improvement over the bill that didn't
have any potential for hold for property
crimes but I think it is I I I could not
support it if the if if the terms of the
change the that allow that would allow
detention are not included and and those
are only included in my in the amendment
that I proposed which is I think eight
nine two so without that I could not
support
um 767. the other point that I the other
point that I would make is although with
that oh well with that change I I I
could support 767 I think that they're
that director ribson has very valid
concerns about excluding simple assault
if uh you know is it is it something
that would cause me to vote against this
bill if it came to the floor assuming
the other changes were made I I I don't
know but I think it I think he does have
valid concerns that I think you should
pay close attention to follow up follow
up so so I I've heard you mentioned a
couple of times that you have an
amendment that you think improves zero
seven six seven and I'm I'm I guess the
question is to the chair uh at what
point should we be entertaining that
alternative that representative Lynn
thinks may be an improvement
I don't have a copy of it um Mr Ripple
all right we'll we'll finish the hearing
on 767 before we introduce the next one
represent and then I have just another
question yes sir this is this is sort of
my final one in this bucket
um
representative Lynn I I have in talking
to people about the changes and
narrowing of the possible charges under
which somebody may be detained or
committed to the the new center
I've heard concerns that if we narrow it
in the real world what we may end up
having is the undetended consequence
unintended consequences of having
prosecutors or judges uh thinking that
the the kid needs to be put somewhere
safe for Public Safety and and that may
tend to cause overcharging to be taking
place and and if and if that is true I'd
like to know if you think that that may
be a valid concern and if it is a valid
concern might we end up doing
um sort of you know some harm to some
kids because they end up getting
overcharged I think that's a very a very
real concern that that I mean if you
know if you if
put yourself in the position of a
prosecutor and and in the first instance
and maybe a judge if if the if the
circumstances are such that that it's
clear to the prosecutor and and later
down the road to the judge that this
person needs to be detained or needs to
be committed
um and and the law you know the law of
let's say of of charging it as a
misdemeanor just completely precludes
that then the the prosecutor is going to
make a strong may very well make a very
strong effort to charge it as a felony
um and and so you know the question I
guess is do you really want
do you really want to sort of tie the
prosecutor's hands so that that that
that's the only alternative you leave
them I I would suggest that
you shouldn't want to do that and
particularly I would suggest that you
shouldn't want to do that where under
the existing law you've had such a a
very significant reduction in the
population of the of the current sununu
Center that's under existing law
um so it that tends to show that you
know prosecutors and judges are
exercising their discretion
appropriately
for the question
so thank you I I wasn't going to ask us
but I think it it dovetails nicely with
that last remark is it is it is it a
correct understanding that currently
under the existing New Hampshire law
that this state
holds the high honor of having the
various very lowest level in the nation
in terms of per capita kids being
committed or detained we're already
number one in the lowest how low can you
go
I you know I have not done any
independent investigation of that but
I've heard that that's true and I guess
the other just one other point that I
would make on that is I and maybe some
other Witnesses if they've done further
research can correct me but at least as
of last year
I know that
um from from others I have again I
haven't done any independent
investigation of this but what I was
what from things that other people have
said it's my understanding that if you
were to adopt the restrict the new
changes that are proposed to to further
restrict offenses that can be the basis
of commitment no other state has gone
that far Illinois I think has maybe has
come the closest but no other state will
have gone as far as we have gone
thank you Mr chair
representative McGuire for question
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
but isn't there a connection between the
list of crimes that can cause commitment
and the size of facility that we need
and the fact that
the number assigned to the facility has
gone down you're attributing it to
um the attitudes of Judges now but but
if the law doesn't doesn't do that
restriction could later judges
start ballooning the number and now we
have a facility that's inadequate well I
I I I mean is it possible that judges in
the future will begin to act
unreasonably I suppose yes I suppose it
is and I suppose if they do
um then that would be the time to change
the law but given given that you know
with the existing law the the
population has gone down tremendously
because I think
you know everybody
has sort of thought that you know that
that has had a different attitude about
the way that that juvenile offenders
should be dealt with
um and I think that's a pretty Broad
you know sort of across the board
spectrum of of of uh where people stand
see none thank you representative thank
you
the next call on representative Marjorie
Smith
thank you Mr chairman Marjorie Smith
representing Durham I'm in my 13th term
and for many of those terms I sat where
you are sitting now
with any number of you on the committee
for two of those terms I was chair of
this committee
and it is because of that that my
conscience
weighs so heavily on me because we have
known for many years
of what was happening at the sununu
center and for any number of reasons or
unable to find a way out
my conscience is heavy
there was a time when uh
the department wanted to have
young people children who were in sununu
eligible for Medicaid not necessarily
because they wanted to have access to
health care for them but because they
wanted the revenue
the federal government came in and we
met with them
and they refused to go along
not because there was barbed wire around
sununa which is one
reason why you would not be eligible for
Medicaid but because
within the facility itself the people
who were operating the facility then
were violating not just federal law but
state law
the federal representative said you are
restraining
juveniles in your facility and you're
putting juveniles into solitary
confinement
and the state representative said well
yeah but but we're working on that we're
trying to figure out how we can find
in violation of what the law that we in
this body had passed that juvenile
should not be restrained
we're not talking here about baseball
we're not talking here about if you
build it they will come we're talking
about young people who are in a system
that is separate from the adult system
because we all know and each year we
find more research that that makes clear
that juvenile brains are not fully
developed
and juveniles cannot be held or should
not be held accountable to the same
standards that you must hold adults I've
listened to words this morning including
crimes
and criminals
juveniles are not
criminals they are juveniles and that is
very very different do we have
horribly troubled confused young people
of course we do and we know that do we
know that the worst thing we can do
is to institutionalize those young
people particularly with other people
who have some of the same problems take
them out of their own communities deny
them
the opportunity to try to find a way
through to where they could become
responsible adults
so my concern is I I disagree as you can
well imagine with the Senate approach of
saying the more the merrier I think we
should have the smallest possible system
I think we should have a system that
makes sure that the greatest extent
possible children are cared for in their
own communities perhaps not in their own
homes but certainly in their own
communities because we want them to be
able to come back and function as adults
in those communities and that is why we
created a juvenile system years ago I
with all due respect to the the my
current chair on Judiciary Committee
um I I think that the attempts that are
being made in this amendment to
recognize
um that yes we need a facility
for for juveniles but we need it to be
small we needed to make sure that
behaviors which are certainly not
acceptable to an adult and certainly are
not acceptable for children are treated
in a way that acknowledges the
difference between a juvenile brain and
an adult brain I I was interested to
hear the representative Edwards I don't
like to I mean he's just left the room
but
talk about uh the child and family law
committee wanting to have this bill to
talk about the crimes because if we're
talking about crimes then I think the
bill should go to criminal justice
but if we're talking about juveniles
then I think that we see the difference
right there between an adult and a child
and as a long time member of this
committee and chair this committee I go
back to what representative McGuire
talked about we have very limited
dollars available in this state and we
have to use standards that are very
clear and are designed to make sure that
we meet the essential needs of the
citizens of the state and know more the
cost that we are incurring in operating
the sununu center the way we are now is
really not justifiable when we see the
long list of other issues that do demand
public attention so I hope that you will
support this effort which as you can see
clearly is a it's not just a bipartisan
effort it's an nonpartisan effort to put
young people
who are in trouble and need help first
and help us find a way to bring those
young people back into society where
they can be productive members so yes I
support this amendment and I thank you
for your time
thank you questions from the committee
members
saying none thank you representative
Smith thank you Mr chair
the next call on director Joe ribson of
the Department of Children Youth and
Family
good morning everybody Joe ripsom
director dcif good to see
um this committee on this issue for I
don't know third time in our division
three colleagues for
I don't know 8th 9th 10th time
um this session so glad to continue the
conversation hopefully we can get um
across the Finish Line with something
that works for for kids and families
here
so I do have
um I first want to be clear we very
strongly support the
replacement of sysc with a smaller
trauma-informed program ideally
co-located in your facility where we
could share services and drive down
operational costs but also ideally share
services that mutually benefit the two
programs so for example if this was to
be co-located near say Hampstead you
would have common clinical common
education Etc if it was to be co-located
near the hospital of New Hampshire
hospital you wouldn't be able to share
this clinical and Education Service
would you be able to share other types
of services to help drive down the
operational costs but there are many
things in this amendment that I am very
very worried about and I'm going to just
try to quickly go through some of them
I'm less worried about than others but
I'm going to mention them just so that
folks have that information for the
future
that talks about changing the name of
the facility I have no problem with
changing the name of the facility but
the purpose of that line was not to
actually rename the facility the purpose
of that line was to make sure that the
new facility lined up with the rest of
the statutory scheme in terms of a Youth
Development Center which is how the rest
of the statute refers to this facility
so if folks want to change the name to
juvenile Treatment Center I wouldn't
object but somebody then has to do the
find and replace through the rest of the
statutory scheme to make sure that those
page 2 line 24 I have really big
concerns about this
so as representative Edwards mentioned
as representative Lynn mentioned we
currently have the lowest rate of
detention and commitment in the country
that's because of a couple things and
and
um representative McGuire mentioned you
know that the law needs to align with
what our expectations are for what kids
can be detained or committed I would say
that that's happened largely already and
I'll go into more detail about that in a
minute
um
and that's part of what is driven down
the need for a detention or commitment
the other big pieces I've shared with
the committee in the past and won't go
super deep on is the creation of a
system of care that's actually allowing
us to Care overwhelmingly for kids in
their own communities right when I came
to this state five years ago we
typically had 70 kids in that building
today we typically have 12. when I came
to the state five years ago we typically
had 200 juveniles and residential
programs Juvenile Justice Youth and
residential programs today we have about
110. so the use of institutionalization
as a remedy for juvenile justice has
gone down radically and not just because
of the change in the law though that was
part of it also because we've built a
robust system of care for Behavioral
Health that's meeting kids needs where
they are based on their needs and not
based on the offenses that they
committed which is the right way to do
this work I'm not going to go too deep
in that but what that ends up resulting
in is the few kids that do get sent to
sysc are very very high needs and very
very intense when you look at Staffing
ratios which shall not exceed those
supported by national accrediting bodies
in K I'm very worried for a couple
things one I don't know what these
National accrediting bodies are because
most juvenile detention centers are not
accredited by a national entity so I'm
not even sure what standards are talking
about but if you Google Staffing ratios
for Juvenile Justice entities what
they'll point to is the Prius standards
the prison rape elimination act
standards which is a one to eight ratio
one staff to eight youth we currently
have 12 very high needs in that facility
if we were to be operating under a Pria
standard of one to eight we would have
two staff for that building
that would be absolutely absurd we would
have law enforcement needs 24 7 to keep
that building just safe and we would
never ever come close to being able to
implement the trauma-informed care that
this bill talks about so I think I have
really big problems with that maybe the
maybe the drafters had a different idea
about what that meant but that's how I
would read this and I think we need to
be very very cautious about that
the next three lines here 25 through 27
I don't really have a problem with us
talking about using this I would just
say that we did result we did consult
this as part of the process that
happened 18 months ago when we came up
with this plan in the first place and
that there are other parts of this plan
that we would continue to consult as we
move through the rest of a closure of
the facility the other things I would
mention though is that this plan was
really drafted not with the intent of
closing the only secured facility in the
state which is what we're talking about
here but it was drafted when talking
about closing one of many
secured facilities in a state right how
do you make the choice between the 20
facilities that you're operating which
one is the one to close so there's a lot
of things in this plan that aren't even
applicable to our situation that being
said the things that are applicable
applicable we looked at the other point
I'd mentioned is we're actually been
invited to this organization's
conference in two months to present on
how we've done this work better than any
other state in the country so you know I
don't really have a problem with with
including this in here but right the
meaning isn't all that isn't all that
significant for our current work
and then I would move forward to
so page five line 11 through 15 does two
different things it talks about the
operating budget not being more than the
average cost operating similar or
Juvenile facility in New England and
that sub and that biannually that that
be reviewed
with the lowest census in the country
with the highest need kids
we are not running the average facility
of anybody else we're running a much
different facility than everybody else
so having us try to have an operational
budget consistent with with averages of
any region or anything doesn't make any
sense
um I know there was a report handed out
at a committee meeting that I wasn't at
that was talking about the cost of
incarcerating children per child if you
review that and you were to compare the
other report that I shared about
detention and commitment rates you would
see that the states that have the lowest
cost per child also lock up the most
kids
what that really is it's a list of who
locks up the most kids and how that's
the cheapest window on your system and I
personally can't be part of a system
that that's the goal of and I don't
think many of us want to be part of a
system for which that's the goal so I
think we need to be really really
thoughtful and careful about things that
would limit the operating costs not
based on the needs of the kids that we
serve or based on the needs of of the
communities but rather based on some
type of average of a facility that is
nothing like the type of thing that
we're doing in New Hampshire because we
are so far ahead of the curve that you
can't compare us to the balance of the
Curve
um page five paragraph or section 7
16-24
I'm not generally opposed to this what
this talks about is the requirements of
the
um director of the facility
our last facility director retired in
January it took us till August to
replace that person and the main reason
why it took so long is that we wanted
somebody that met these criteria that
they actually had an advanced degree
that they're actually licensed clinician
that they actually did all that work so
we did fill that position this is in
line with the person that's currently
running the facility who I think is
doing an amazing job and it's in line
with what I would hope going forward I
would just caution that when you put
these types of things in statute it does
tie hands and who knows years from now
whether we're going to have a hard time
finding somebody with those
qualifications again I I don't really
oppose it because it's exactly what
we've looked for and exactly what I
think we'll continue to look for but you
know we are you're tying the hands of
future people that might have to make
decisions in in scarcity and that that's
a tough thing I'd point to the example
of our colleagues down in Rhode Island
who have been out without a permanent
child welfare director for almost four
years now because there is requires that
it be a master's prepared social worker
and they've been unable to find a
master's prepared social worker willing
to step into that job
now the biggest concerns that we heard
most about have to do with these next
few sections section eight and nine
which start on page five line 24 and go
through
page I guess you're referring to a
different uh Amendment oh I'm sorry am I
I I think you just meant line 25 not 24.
page five yeah page five line 25 through
and I am working on a printout that I
got before this morning so it is
through Page 721 so this is what's been
referred to as the HB 254 language
so a couple things that I think the
committee needs to understand one I do
think it would be helpful to have you
know the other committees look at this
who who go deeper into this work on a
regular basis but moreover
this language talks about commitment
right and we've had this conversation
before but commitment refers to the time
at which we're making a decision that a
child needs to be placed after you've
adjudicated them but other parts of the
law disallow you to also detain a young
person that's a temporary immediate
detention for things that are not
committable right so even though this
talks about commitment it equally
applies to detention
the big change here is
I'm not so concerned with the first part
of this because the second part is you
know is where most of this would come in
so that's section nine
So currently very very few kids get
detained or committed at sysc the
reasons for that like I said system of
this document which I'm happy to share
thank you Kevin
that is the detention assessment and
screening tool
which is a court form which was put
together by people who actually work
with kids in these situations on a
regular basis right public defenders
prosecutors probation officers
clinicians judges they put this together
to help them guide the decision as to
who gets detained or committed
I heard comments when I shared the data
in the past about how you saw the
commitment levels drop so radically but
detention levels really didn't move that
radically that's because they were using
this for years before the change in the
law that's what drove detention levels
down and it was done not just because of
the change in the law but because the
people who do the work care to try to
get that done
and what this sets up is different types
of offenses
and you can see that on the back couple
Pages here
and it sets up different scores for
different types of offenses as to when
they'd be eligible for detention or
commitment really this is just for
level four offenses are similar to the
things that are listed in the statute
right murder stuff like that absolutely
level three offenses little less severe
typical felonies though level two
offenses are things like Class A
misdemeanors things like simple assault
domestic violence and yes as
representative wholes said stealing an
iPad could be a Class A misdemeanor but
that is not the extent of what consists
of Class A misdemeanors and they have
never seen in five years a kid go to
sysc because they stole an iPad that's
not why they go there they go there
because there's issues of violence in
the home violence somewhere in the
community
and this tool is what's guiding that so
if you look at the back two pack few
pages of this it has a list of all the
criminal offenses and it gives them a
level score
you would notice on here that simple
assault and domestic violence are only a
out of four if you go back to the first
page here
you'll see that a level two offense only
gets four points
the way that this process works you need
to get 12 points to be recommended for
detention so typically a simple a
smaller domestic violence Class A
misdemeanor is not going to get you
detained or committed but what the rest
of this tool does is it goes through the
more nuanced things that a judge has to
think through when measuring Community
safety and risk to the child themselves
things like what other charges are
currently pending or have been recently
disposed of
has this child recently absconded or run
away
things like
um you know there's also score things
that reduce the score right if the kids
got you know a safe place to return to
and this allows a judge to actually make
a nuanced decision about whether it's
appropriate to detain or commit a kid
and I would say the evidence that this
is working is the fact that we have the
lowest rate of detained kids in the
country there is one state that has a
lower detained alone than us that's
Maine they report zero I believe that
that's inaccurate I think it's a
semantical issue because they called
attention shock commitment so their
commitment numbers are really high their
detention numbers are zero if you
exclude that we have the lowest level of
detained kids in the entire country not
just attending committed combined but
detained and that's because we're really
good at trying to be careful not to use
this where we don't need to use it
so
I am really worried about these changes
in section 9 because
where you put a Class A misdemeanor as
only being eligible for detention where
there are three prior defenses within
the past 12 months there is a potential
for a situation where you have a young
person who may be committed an act of
domestic violence
and is not safe to return home because
of that
but it cannot be elevated to a felony
level because of the severity of the
injury the biggest difference between
kind of a simple assault and an
aggravated assault or assault too is the
severity of the injury it's not really
about the incident or what the kid did
it's about how bad was the other person
hurt right and that really isn't the
measure I think that should be kind of
the end all be-all of the consideration
of whether safe kid is safe to return
home or safe to go somewhere else it
needs to be more nuanced in the way that
the courts and the people who do this
work have already thought through very
thoroughly
um
moreover than that though this change
will not meaningfully impact the census
of sysc
there are almost no kids that get
detained for a single simple assault or
a single domestic violence charge
overwhelmingly those kids are already
going to residential settings but the
fact that that safety valve exists
within the system allows law enforcement
prosecutors to feel comfortable
deferring bringing charges against kids
so you heard a bit of a conversation
with representative Lynn about concerns
that you could see prosecutors or judges
up charging kids or more more
significant that what I'm more worried
about as you see prosecutors being less
willing to defer bringing charges at all
because they're going to feel like they
need to get their three priors to make
sure that that kid's eligible for sysc
and doing this now when we're just in
the midst of implementing what I think
is a revolutionary change in the way
that we make these decisions for kids
would be terrible we just passed SB 94
about a year or so ago we've been
implementing it for a year now what SB
94 does is every time law enforcement
has contact with a kid
they come to us we do a child adolescent
needs and strengths tool assessment and
then we make a recommendation back to
law enforcement is this a kid that needs
to go to court or is this a kid that we
can use one of our many Community
Options instead
72 percent of the time we're saying
there's this kid shouldn't go to court
you shouldn't even bring this kid to
court in the first place this kid should
go to a community-based service and
totally avoid the Juvenile Justice
System
94 of the time law enforcement is
agreeing with us
that's under the current system where
they know they have that safety valve if
they really need it if we were to change
the Dynamics here I very much worry that
you're going to find law enforcement
being really reluctant to defer filing
cases against kids because instead of
knowing that they have a safety valve
just in case things get too heavy and
there's an incident violence that they
need to respond to they're going to be
thinking I need to get three strikes or
else I'm not going to have that safety
valve in place
and at the time when we're really seeing
radical change in our system as a result
of the implementation of SB 94 I think
that would be devastating I think we
would see all the progress that we've
seen over the past couple years start to
erode because you would have law
enforcement not trusting the ability of
the system to respond to community
safety when necessary and again it
almost never happens I hear of it
happening one or two times a year of a
kid who has less than three priors but
when it happens it's typically
short-term detention it's typically to
try to make sure that the family is safe
and that you have a safe place to have
that kid go and then within a couple
days you're able to work it out where
either the kids able to safely return
home or go to another family member or
anything else the other thing that
impact this is that there's no ability
in our system to temporarily hold a
child anywhere other than detaining them
at sysc right you can't temporarily hold
a child in an adult a municipal facility
the laws around that are that kids can
only stay there for a matter of a couple
hours for processing and they need to
move to sysc so if you take this tool
away you don't even have the opportunity
to kind of let some the colder heels at
the county or at the local local jail
while you're working things out you just
take that totally away from the system
and then I have a couple other
I'm okay with the changes that start on
page seven regarding trauma-informed
care that's that's fine with me if this
was to go forward I do think there's an
error in the applicability at least on
the version that I was working on let me
double check if it's the same in this
version
yeah so page eight
line one talks about sections seven and
eight
applying to cases where a dispositional
order is not up in order section seven
was about the qualifications of the sysc
director so I don't think that's what
the intent was I think the intent was
for that to be eight and nine
not seven and eight and with that I am
happy to
take any questions
thank you any questions from the
representative welcome to you next thank
you Mr chair
um
thank you Commission
commissions a lot of information
could maybe write us a
that includes all the
questions and comments you had
I could I'm not I'm very busy and and it
will take me a minute but if that's
something that the committee would like
I I could do that I I didn't hear the
some sort of
a summary of all the comments he's made
and all the corrections and
ideas he had for changes in the bill I
think they're significant and helpful
thank you
I'm also happy to if there's a work
session where folks want to go through
this I'm happy to sit through that too
if that's helpful
representative Edwards for a question
uh thank you Mr chair
um I'm looking at
um the uh the handout that you gave us
on the state of New Hampshire judicial
branch the the multi-page document where
um I don't see a page number but it's it
headlines detention assessment screening
instrument instructions
there's RSA cited there are specific
offenses cited uh I I I I see crime
levels those all look like criminal code
issues to me so my my question is that
since we formed a
a new general court in January of 23
just a few weeks ago
bills in this area have been heard and
voted out 24 to nothing by the Senate
children and family law have looked at a
similar bill that they've retained
because they think they they want to be
able to work on it division three
finances has worked on it is this the
first time in this legislative session
that you've seen a specific Amendment or
discussion related to changing the
criminal offenses for which a juvenile
could be detained or committed yes
thank you
further questions from committee members
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you commissioner for
being here so this form that the
judicial branch uses is it spelled out
in statute for the judges to use this
form or is this a practice that they've
adopted that they could change so it's
not spelled out in statute but the
courts the courts instructor judges that
they have to use these forms when
they're doing these things and this was
this was originally written I don't know
tenor so years ago and then it was
updated with the Law changes that
occurred whenever that was 2018-ish to
that so you see that kind of section B
here that's to incorporate this stuff
from 2018 that occurred so it's
consistent with the law but the law
doesn't specifically require that the
form be used thank you very much
further questions from committee members
seeing none thank you director
and we'll look forward to you at work
sessions
Mr chair can can Mr ribson stick around
uh for representative Lynn's
he affirms that thank you sir and we'll
I'm sorry can you hear me now
good morning Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Cody
bellander I'm from Epping former member
of the past legislative session
if you remember I stood before our
session and told you that I have
personal experience
I'm also the chair of the Juvenile
Justice Reform Commission which has
I'm tired of watching this get punted
back and forth
I look at the bills I pay attention and
what I see is very similar to Washington
DC it's not a clean bill
trash
we have been excuse me
New Hampshire has been looked at
as an opportunity to build a
state-of-the-art facility
a facility
not policy
we're getting there
through diversion programs that have
been established over the years we have
seen a decline in committed youth
we have what what's the census today
10. students
or juvenile offenders if you will
when I was there
bull
they've all told you we want a facility
a new facility one that's home base
we had a work session and my first term
for the summer
where we heard so many solutions brought
before us
someone had the audacity to recommend
how depressed do you think that that
student or juvenile offender would be if
he rolls up to Rockingham County jail
and sees all the barbed wire
not very
be very depressed
the opportunity that's before you is to
build a facility take the policy out of
it
put the policy into a separate bill
18 bits
you've we've seen the numbers that's
what supports
we had a whole two years
when I was in the legislature
in an attempt to do to do this right and
here we are again
Senate Bill 93 or 98 director last year
excuse me Senate bill 94.
provide a diversion
to prevent kids from even being arrested
and we're not talking about the habitual
offenders the 10 out of 10 offenders
we're talking about the kids with
low-level crime
or New Hampshire a population of one
point almost 4 million people
we don't have very many high risk
offenders
but you can't just go to zero you'll
never be able to do that
we'll never be able to completely wipe
out not having a facility which has been
floated
so then what
you're going to send these kids to
Massachusetts
Illinois
Tennessee
article after article after article has
proven that kids are successful if only
one adult shows that they care about
these kids I am living proof that that
can happen I've sat on the other side of
this table because one person cared
about me enough and told me that they
loved me
when I thought the end was never going
now of course some of you might be
thinking I'm not going to listen to this
guy he didn't win
he's just on a soapbox
maybe somebody on the other side of the
screen watching
of the other 400.
but the opportunity to build a facility
that fits the need of the system of care
that we've been building for years even
before I became a legislator when I was
we have the ability to do that what we
need to focus on what I believe should
be the focus is the building and what
goes on and how it's built
not what goes on on the inside that
should not be the focus
that can be a focus for the second part
of the session
but the main focus
should be the studs the brick and the
mortar
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the committee and I'm happy
to take any questions
thank you any questions from committee
members
representative Edwards all right thank
you Mr chair and um thank you uh
honorable Belanger hey I think I heard
you essentially testify that you're
opposed to zero six zero seven six seven
and if I heard you right as a former
state representative
do you think that perhaps this bill
should be redirected over to Children
and Family Law so that they can consider
it as the policy committee
uh thank you representative Edwards for
the question as a member of a former
member of that committee I do believe
that if this is policy that's where that
any further questions from committee
members
um
other interested people I have seven
cards before me people wishing to
testify
um
we've gone fairly long on many of these
people testifying so if there's
something that's mostly been said and I
see the majority of you are opposed to
the bill if you could just
not repeat repeat any of the testimony
we've heard but give your personal
reasons why you oppose the bill I would
appreciate it it may I ask for
clarification sir you're saying they're
opposed to the bill or they're opposed
to this amendment I I just want to be
clear all I have is what's checked on
good morning members of the committee
I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy
director at the disability rights Center
I'm here on behalf of the disability
rights Center as well as on behalf of
the juvenile reform policy Group which
is an advocacy group comprised of
disability rights Center New Hampshire
legal assistance the ACLU of New
Hampshire
um the um oh my goodness I'm gonna
forget Waypoint new Futures and the
children's Law Center of New Hampshire
and that those pink cards are
challenging so I mean if you don't color
well inside the lines so the position
that we're taking is this we fully
support the development of a replacement
facility for the sununu center however
we have issues with the amendment that's
under consideration right now and
concerns about those and that's what we
will highlight so I will limit my
testimony to a few of those issues and
then one of my colleagues who is much
more familiar with the juvenile
sentences and Provisions will address
those and I'll do my best to keep it
short
so
um with that clarification
the provision that I believe director
ribson did address has to do with staff
ratio it's section two
um Roman three
small letter J it's on page 24.
um so as the Director explained to you
there really aren't a lot of Standards
or accreditation for Juvenile Justice
facilities and what we look to are
things like the prison rape elimination
act or Priya which calls for a one to
eight ratio and I understand the way I
look at this provision
perhaps it's an effort to be in line
with this committee's responsibility
spending State dollars responsibly
but I also think the committee needs to
invest New Hampshire dollars responsibly
and with an eye towards how we can do
that in a way that will ensure good
outcomes the best outcomes for kids who
are really vulnerable and in our state
you know with so few children who are in
this system eligible for commitment that
will do it in a way that these children
will come out better than when they went
in
so
you know we are not a state that
subjects kids to secure confinement when
they are when they shoplift graffiti do
minor crimes like we're talking about
some pretty serious offenses that are
causing kids to be ordered to a new new
center and there aren't very many of
them so when we're looking at economies
of scale here you know and and what's
required for these children they're
going to need adequate staff because
these are children with very serious
emotional issues very serious trauma
and behavioral challenges that are
difficult to manage
what I think is that the only way that
this really small population of really
high-end challenging children could be
addressed with a ratio of like one to
eight would be essentially to keep kids
locked in their rooms because otherwise
you're going to have kids and staff in
unsafe situations
that's like putting kids into solitary
confinement that's not therapeutic
that's counter therapeutic it's not what
the goal is here the goal is to provide
a therapeutic evidence-based
trauma-informed treatment center for
these kiddos and can room confinement to
keep them safe because we don't have
adequate staff to supervise and engage
with them just shouldn't be an option
for this committee
um
the provision I don't really understand
is the following one letter k
um the Strategic downsides and
considerations I've really I'm baffled
by why it's there
um as I understand what this um
Council on juvenile Corrections
administrators did was they helped
develop a format for states that have
multiple facilities to consider how they
can shut down facilities I didn't read
the information I was able to find
online to suggest that it would me it
would be for the closure of all
facilities in a state and I think that
the Alvarez and Marcel report all the
community meetings that took place
really were in keeping with a lot of the
recommendations so I don't I guess I
don't understand why it's there the next
section that I want to address is the
the excuse me
the operating budget
I mean similarly to what my first point
I think what we're talking about here is
yes we have an obligation to spend State
dollars responsibly but we also need to
invest them responsibly and and Staffing
and numbers of children go hand in hand
um there is the provision requires a
budget that is I think commensurate with
the average cost per child to operate a
similar Juvenile Justice Facility in New
England there aren't any
there just aren't
so
um our goal is to do something different
and and the operating budget the per
child operating budget is going to be
higher than it is to operate a Juvenile
jail essentially where your housing
40 50 80 100 children so when we're
talking about 12 children
it is going to cost more I mean there's
there's no way to hide that but we've
got to keep the needs of our children
front and center here their treatment
and safety needs and the goal that when
they leave this facility they'll be
better off than when they went in
so
um
it's just it is going to be more
expensive to
for do you have an adequate operating
budget for students and children in a
facility that promotes healing and
evidence-based care while simultaneously
protecting the security and safety of
our communities and that's going to be
much more expensive than warehousing
children in a Juvenile Justice Facility
that houses many more lower level
offenders so for all these reasons the
testimony you heard from director ripson
in particular I ask that you vote
against this proposed amendment and that
you support something more along the
lines of what representative Edwards had
put forward in his Amendment and I'll
take any questions you might have
thank you any questions from committee
members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you well next call on Susan
Stearns
um for the record my name is Susan
Stearns I'm the executive director of
Nami New Hampshire the National Alliance
on Mental Illness
the testimony that's being passed around
was actually written by our director of
public policy Holly Stevens who is
literally digging her way out of her
home still and unable to be here today
so
um Nami New Hampshire is a Grassroots
organization working to improve the
lives of all people impacted by mental
illness and suicide through support
education advocacy
um while we applaud the work of this
committee and I actually feel privileged
to have been in the room today to hear
the discussion and recognize
how New Hampshire is such a leader in
this field I'm grateful that opportunity
we do oppose this amendment and I won't
go into detail you have heard clearly
um the concerns around sufficient funds
for the staffing ratio as well as
ensuring that the treatment does meet
the needs of these high need children I
will say we know that many of these
children have mental health challenges
and we know that statistically children
with mental health challenges are far
more likely to wind up in our adult
criminal justice system so investment
Here and Now for these kiddos will
ultimately save us money long term as
well as well as probably lead to much
better outcomes for most of them
I'm happy to take any questions although
I really wish Holly were here to respond
to them
thank you for your brevity questions
from the committee members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you well let's next call on Renee
foreign
good morning thank you
um so this is actually going to be quick
because what I prepared was kind of
covered by everyone so uh but I wanted
to thank you for recognizing yes I
wanted to kind of give a practical
um uh opposition if you will so I am the
executive director of Dover Children's
Home I also sit on the Juvenile Justice
Reform Commission
um so we run a level two residential
treatment program which essentially is
community based so our kids go to school
in the community they work in the
community and they live in a home-based
environment we run our program uh
restraint and seclusion free and we have
for 17 years
however we are able to do that because
we run our program on a ratio of one to
three
what this is asking for is a ratio of
one to eight if we line it up with Prius
standards which is completely
inappropriate unsafe and absolutely will
never meet the treatment needs of Youth
that's all I have to say
thank you
questions from any committee members
seeing none thank you well next call on
running honorable chair at members of
the committee my name is Michelle
wongren I'm the youth Law Project
Director at New Hampshire legal
assistance and I'm also here testifying
on behalf of the juvenile reform policy
group as my colleague Karen Rosenberg
previously mentioned so I'm going to
focus my testimony today on the HB 254
Amendment so that would be Section 8 and
9 of the bill and
um I've been involved in in this project
redeveloping this new new center this
was a standalone Bill several years ago
and has been through the policy
committee several times well I think
that this is an improvement to some of
those earlier versions of the bill which
were very confusing I continue to have
some major concerns about both the bill
itself and also the need for the bill so
first of all I think that this needs to
be done separate from Redevelopment of
the student center and the reason for
that is because it doesn't actually
affect the census of the sununu center
as you heard from director there may be
one or two kids that it it could impact
but the reality is is that the way it's
morphed over time is that although their
um the initial provisions of the bill
try to limit the door to Serious violent
crime there are enough catch-alls now in
this version of the bill that my
perception is that it's a net zero it
doesn't actually do anything so what
what that leads me to do is if we're
writing legislation that does nothing we
have to be concerned about what harm it
will do and what we just heard from
director ribsum is very concerning there
has been great work with SB 94
um the the front door has been narrowed
to the sununu center in recent years not
because of closure
um of closing off the offenses but
because we have prioritized diversion
and that is a very real policy goal that
has had very real impact if we want to
further narrow the door I don't think
the right way to do that is by by
closing the door but by building up the
system of care those kids who are
first-time offenders committing domestic
violence offenses at home either against
their parents or their siblings we need
to build up the system of care to be
able to manage those kids in the
community if they are low-level
offenders we shouldn't just say well
you're not welcome at the sununu center
because because you have to go somewhere
else but where else do we where else do
we send them or better what services do
we provide to them are we sure that
there's mobile crisis services that are
effective enough to deal with that
situation if not let's look at that
because the reality is is that when kids
are determined to need commitment and
the door is closed to them
they don't go home they don't go to the
community-based services or the judges
would be ordering those community-based
Services instead where they go are out
of state facilities like Mill Creek and
if you and Mill Creek in Arkansas and
when you look at Mill Creek's website
they build themselves as a long-term and
we're talking like
nine to 18 months long-term treatment
facility for out-of-state students or
out-of-state youth not even their own
youth but out of state youth why are we
sending kids to an out-of-state facility
that welcomes in out-of-state youth to
provide long-term treatment to them
that's not who we are as a state that's
not where we're going as a state and so
rather than looking at can we stop two
kids from going to the sununu center and
risk completely upending HB or SB 94
let's look at doing something meaningful
to these kids in the policy group where
I think that bill belongs and where that
work belongs so all of this to say is
that I strong I'm here strongly in
support of amendment
804h and strongly against 767 age for
all of the reasons that you've heard
today I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions from committee
Bruce
we will next call on Cassandra Sanchez
good morning committee members and thank
you for my for your time today I will
share that I will keep it extremely
brief many of my colleagues before me
did share many of the concerns that I
have here I'm just going to focus as my
role as a child advocate for the state
is the best interests of these children
and keeping our children in New
Hampshire
um so what I will share with you is my
concern for the statement around ratio
of the children and staff in the
facility I will share I had an
opportunity to go out to Arkansas over
the summer and I had an opportunity to
experience their Treatment Center where
they house over a hundred youth in one
Center and in that sense as their
juvenile detention center and in their
Juvenile Detention Center
they had very low staff ratios and at
the time that I was visiting one of the
Cottages they had a ratio of two staff
to 12 children and what that resulted in
was what they called a cottage system
and what that means is that half of the
the children were in their rooms for
half of the day while the other children
can move about the cottage then they
would take turns switching the other
half would be released they would move
about the cottage the other half would
remain in their rooms for for that time
period and the time that I was there
that because there were additional
um adults in the room they were allowed
to let the children out and so we had an
opportunity to speak with the children
in groups and what they shared was how
that felt for them to be trapped they
shared the experience of feeling like
animals all day long and they did not
have any dignity and respect because
they were held in their rooms because
Staffing did not allow for any changes
and I was there with an advocate from
Arkansas who was working diligently to
remove that Cottage system for these
kids because she recognized how damaging
that system was I do not want to see us
join in Arkansas and treat the children
of New Hampshire in that same way our
children deserve much more dignity and
respect and what they truly deserve is
treatment we understand these are
children with extremely high needs and
to be able to deliver trauma-informed
care and utilize a therapeutic
approaches that we would like to see in
the sununu center we need a new facility
that the building spaces trauma informed
and that the ra the ratios are similar
to what we just heard from Dover
Children's Home that therapeutic
approach we need to be looking at this
new facility and comparing it closer to
what our residential facilities look
like because those are the areas in the
state where our children get treatment
they have the ability to make the
necessary changes to be successful and
safe in the community and then they have
those opportunities to return to the
community and be successful
we have seen that work for our children
and so we need to look for that for the
new facility I will also share in my
time in Arkansas I had an opportunity to
visit Mill Creek in Arkansas I did visit
that that residential facility and under
and met with the children from New
Hampshire that that reside there and I
understand as a state of New Hampshire
we send many children there what I will
say is that is a practice that I would
like to see us be able to scale back on
and in doing that we need to ensure that
we have the appropriate Treatment
available here we are doing that through
building out the children's system of
care we need to continue to pour our
money and our efforts into that
community-based system so that we can
keep our children here and in programs
or in the community in New Hampshire it
is quite unfortunate to see that we are
sending children to a facility where
their own state will not send their
children there although they are
licensed they will not send their
children there because they hold
concerns for them and so realistically
we want to ensure that even even our
children in the in juvenile justice
system we want to keep them here to get
treatment here so in the long run as
they as they moved into adulthood
they're not costing the system more
money on the other end when children
don't have the opportunity to get the
appropriate treatment and reform we see
them costing more money in the adult
system and if it although it is a lot of
money we're asking up front now to
invest in our children we believe that
the long run outcome will be worth it
thank you
thank you can you give us a number of
New Hampshire children and why they were
sent there was it the court or was it
some other function I don't have the
exact number for today
um when I visited there were four
children there
um we do have times where there's more
or less children at the facility some
have been sent there because their needs
could not be met at a residential
facility in the state of New Hampshire
with again with building out the
children's system of care as well as
investing in Hampstead Hospital and a
level 5 prtf to be built at that
facility that can resolve some of this
issue and sending children to to out of
state but that a lot of it is that their
needs could not be met at the level of
programming here
so this was less confining than if we'd
I some of the some of the children that
I do understand that have gone to Mill
Creek were eligible for the sununu
center um but ultimately
um they were able to with with great
advocacy on their end
um were able to go the route of
placement in a residential facility as
opposed to sununu Center
um I in the future if that if if we are
struggling with said Youth and they have
that level of charges and we know that
the new replacement facility is a
treatment facility where they're getting
adequate care and they have that option
or to go out of state the advocacy may
be otherwise the the attorneys that are
supporting these youth May advocate for
them to stay at sununu knowing that
they're getting the treatment that they
need and that's one of the reasons why
we need to have the facility that has
that approach in this state
thank you questions from committee
members represent Edwards and
representative bucco so thank you Mr
chair I I just to let you know I think I
have three questions that may require a
paragraph answer so sorry
um because she's the state's child
advocate I just want to make sure I'm
clear on a few points
um there are
experienced senior legislators who have
proposed that if we do not have the
capacity at our new facility that we
ought to just be prepared to send
juveniles out of state what what what do
you think our position as a state ought
to be on the option of removing
our citizens to another state for
confinement
it's quite concerning to consider out of
state the option the solution as you
heard before me some are speaking about
families these children have families
they have connections to this state they
have friendships they have other
motivators to stay on track and to do
the right thing and if we keep them in
their Community close to those
motivators then they have the success to
return back to their communities and to
so thank you Mr chair and similarly I've
heard from many of the same senior folks
that um
that if we have a capacity issue at the
new facility and we end up with
additional placements that need to be
made that what that ought to do is
trigger sort of a mandatory release of a
resident prior to them having completed
their treatment what what what what do
you think the appropriate State position
ought to be relative to an artificially
early
pre-treatment release of a resident who
is otherwise supposed to be at a at this
facility
those administrative releases need to
consider the clinical impact there is a
great clinical team that exists in the
current facility and there may be times
where an administrative releases a
conversation but they have a seat at
that table to say what needs to be in
place for that youth to be successful so
there may be times where the youth may
not be have completed their treatment at
the facility but there may be adequate
treatment options in the community that
they can transition to as long as that
is being explored in the clinical lens
is part of that conversation then that
could be reasonable but if it's
administrative release only for capacity
and not taking into account that child's
needs and treatment needs then that
could create a problem because that
could be a youth that's released too
early and will end up right back in the
system
follow up okay and I I've also sort of
uh and previous hearings heard people
bring up the the horrible history of the
sununu center relative to the abuse of
kids and uh the basic question you know
why would you know insanity is doing the
same thing over and expecting a
different result well I I is it your
understanding that we're what we're
proposing with these other amendments is
something fundamentally different than
what we've done historically in terms of
uh providing for the issues related to
these kids
absolutely uh that that's where the
therapeutic trauma-informed care comes
in that is fundamentally different than
the way in which the facility was
operated in the past it takes skilled
staff who understand what these children
have experienced in their lives prior to
getting to the setting to uh to be able
to engage in that trauma-informed care
and so if we're looking for more skilled
staff hopefully salaries that match that
skill level will be getting staff that
can't adequately meet these children's
needs not staff who are are frustrated
and burnt out within their positions and
don't have the ability to deal with some
of the difficulties that come with
managing their trauma in this setting
and settling into an Institutional like
setting so I do believe we have that in
place we also have the office of the
child advocate which did not exist at
that time and my office receives in real
time the any restraint and seclusion
that's occurring or any incidents in
general that occur at the facility and
so we're able to look at those in real
time as they come in assess what has
happened and any concerns that we see
within the facility within specific
staff or specific children the ways in
which they're responding to those
children we can intervene early on
before it gets too far thank you Mr
Sharon thank you Mr Sanchez thank you
representative Buco for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Advocate
Sanchez this uh this Arkansas facility
with the cottage facility is this a
for-profit facility because that's what
it sounds like yes
follow up on that is is a for-profit
facility
um would that be adequate for the type
of
inmates or
people that need to be in this in this
facility I don't believe for-profit
should be an option on the table when
we're looking at a replacement for the
current sysc I believe what needs to be
state run it allows the level of
oversight that we currently have in the
facility to ensure safety of the
children and it also allows for some of
those shared services as you as you've
heard from director ribsum and sharing
services with a facility like Hampstead
Hospital or um or new or um
the hospital in Concord so with the
shared services as well as the skill and
ability of the staff differs when you
take a look at at private versus
for-profit so I don't even believe that
that's something we should be bringing
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
welcome
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is John
dejoy
I rise in full support
as I'm sitting listening to the
testimonies that I feel I remember Yogi
Berra
I remember Yogi Berra because this
really does feel like deja vu all over
again
um we I'm working on this issue for more
than a decade and I'm very proud of the
work that I've done
much of it with my former colleagues who
you've heard testify against this
but I think it's important
that we shouldn't make a decision
because we're frustrated
we shouldn't make a decision
this is a decision that affects the
lives of currently all 12 children
now admittedly it's a low number
it may be the lowest in the country
but I think that's irrelevant for this
discussion
because we're still talking about the
lies of 12 children
and the decisions you make today will
affect their lives
this is very much a financial Bill even
with the policy implications because the
policy implications go directly to the
census of the facility you've heard
people testify that that the sections
that are known as House Bill 254 would
have no impact on the census I disagree
with that
and I will tell you if I'm wrong
two years from now I'll stand up here
and testify that I was wrong
I don't believe I am
this is not nor ever has been about a
building
but most of the discussion over the last
decade and in the last two years has
focused on what the building's going to
look like how big the building's going
to be how many beds there are
and we have very little conversation
there has been some today but very
little conversation about the treatment
children need
that is and always should be our Focus
what is in the best interest to this
incarcerating children is not in their
we know that because research tells us
that
we also know the legislature understands
that because throughout the statutes it
says repeatedly least restrictive
alternative
children should not be incarcerated
unless it is the least restrictive
alternative but we've heard today lots
of reasons why children should be
incarcerated that are not least
I want to share some data that I've I
haven't I've
I've just tried to decide whether I
should share it or not this is data from
the department and I'm sure the
department can get you the full report
from 2021.
let's understand who these children are
okay
we know from past testimony from the
Department that maybe 75 percent it's
not my number
of the children have Behavioral Health
needs
many children have learning disabilities
many children live in poverty
what we've never talked about beyond
that who these kids are well the report
from the Department
indicates that
most
that many of these children are children
and I'm referring to the Department's
data this is I just printed out a few
pages which I can share I'd recommend
you get this from the Department not for
me but this looks at calendar year 2017
18 and 19 regarding Juvenile Justice
and in 2019
of all arrests referred to the court
we're children of color
in that year children of color
represented 13 of the entire child
population
but when you look at kids referred for
forty percent of the kids referred for
secure 37.9 percent of the kids referred
for secured attention are children of
color
but yet they represent
a quarter of that
and 49.3 of all children committed to
the center of Youth Services Center are
We Believe very for there's a there is a
policy disagreement
that is affecting the budgeting and the
we believe that children who are
incarcerated at sununa Youth Services
Center or the replacement facility
should be kids who commit or are charged
with serious violent offenses
we believe the system of care exists
to treat the remainder of the children
who do not commit serious violent
offenses
I have always argued to close the senior
Youth Services Center lock it up and
throw away the key
through this process over the last
several years it has become clear that
there will be a small fraction of
children
who we need to have the ability to
incarcerate
because of Public Safety or the
perception of Public Safety
but contrary to representative Lynn I do
not consider property crime
to be a serious violent offense I
consider to be an offense I consider it
something the child should be held
accountable for
and I consider it something that the
child should pay
compensation or provide service for I
incinitiative Services Center or any
other incarcerated setting
we talk about trauma-informed care which
is there's Universal agreement that is
the approach
trauma-informed care begins with the
culture of the facility
when you folks
two decades ago decided to build this
new Services Center part of the reason
was that YDC
was having significant issues with
allegations of abuse
also had a very high recidivism rate
you folks decided to build a snowy
Services Center which you were assured
at the time by the people who aren't
here today
that the treatment would be better at
this in Union Services Center
and we picked up YDC and moved it to
sysc
and we had the same issues at sysc
as we had at YDC
I believe the number today is more than
a thousand children have alleged sexual
you have a generational decision before
you once this is decided we won't
revisit this for at least a decade and
probably two
you have the opportunity to take steps
to make sure that the facility that it
replaces this
whether it's today tomorrow or next year
is an optimal treatment facility for
children
that's what this amendment does it adds
prevents children who who don't commit
serious violent offenses from being
incarcerated or detained
and adds pieces to explain what
trauma-informed care is and to try to
put safeguards in place to make sure
that charm and Ford care is actually
what is delivered
I can go through the 254 pieces line by
line event we would like me to I've done
that before this committee a couple
times in the past some of you weren't
here many of you were I will remind the
committee this was part of the budget
two years ago
when you all had the courage to set a
closure date for sysc
now we had to push out the closure date
but the only reason we're here having
those conversations because you had the
courage to do that
I'm asking you to have the courage to
disc continue disagreeing with the
Senate
to move forward with what is truly going
to help children
and worry less about what the facility
looks like and what the treatment
delivered inside the facility consists
of we think this amendment does that
and I would ask you to support the
amendment
I would say representative rice
wanted to be here
she was unable to be here because she's
still stuck in her driveway she did
submit testimony electronically and has
I could keep going Mr chairman I won't
but there were a lot of things said
previously that I normally would comment
on I think I'd like to focus my
testimony as I have that this is a
generational decision and it's in your
hands
I hope you'll support this amendment
which Builds on the work of
Representative Edwards in the Senate and
adds important pieces to it to fully
flesh out what this facility ought to
representative Petrie for a question
right thank you Mr chairman I just need
funny question today I represent myself
I've done this work over the last decade
representing several clients today I
represent myself right I see the orange
badge just one yeah I have other clients
I do not have a client that's asked me
to represent them on this issue thank
further questions from committee members
representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my questions I just have two
um does this amendment take a position
on sending children out of state
thank you for the question
representative in fact nothing in this
amendment
specifies a particular standard for for
Staffing Nora does it contemplate
sending children on a state we we agree
that sending children out of state is a
last leased alternative and as I
understand it it's typically done today
for Unique types of treatment needs that
the state does not have the ability to
offer in state I would say further that
we actually looked at the Prius
standards
and rejected the priest energy of heard
the one to eight we don't believe that's
reasonable
so it was an intent that St that
statement was an intent to address what
is seen as a bloated budget
for this facility
if it's causing more confusions
um by all means remove it
however it does not refer to the prehist
standards
all right follow up thank you
and are there non-detension facilities
available in New Hampshire
so the system of care as I understand it
and I'm going to be speaking out of turn
because this is not my expertise Mr
ribsum can speak to this more expertly
than I can but the system of care
provides a number of types and
intensities of care as I understand it
there are group homes which are go up to
a level four type group home which based
on the contracts can deal with children
who are adjudicated
um so yeah there are there are and
they're technically considered
non-secure I believe
further questions from the committee
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair thank you for uh Mr dejoy for
taking my question I
um I it it's my impression that one of
the reasons that there hasn't been as
much dialogue this term as opposed to
previous terms but in this term about
the the operations of the facility is
because there's just
devastatingly broad consensus that we're
trying to build an entirely new model
here a therapeutic model that's
trauma-informed and since there's not
really been any disagreement on that I
don't think that there's been much
discussion on it the discussion for
quite a while has been focused on
something very specific and and my
question to you is
um the the specific issue has been the
maximum capacity of the facility there
were advocates for six then there were
advocates for 12 with the potential of
going up to 18 should a exigent reason
exist
what is your position on the maximum
capacity do you have a number that you
would tell us
thank you for the question and just to
start I reject the premise that this
broad consensus there is Broad consensus
regarding trauma-informed care and I can
support that
you know right after you folks set a
closure date I met with the commissioner
and the director with a number of other
Advocates and the commissioner asked me
the very same question how many beds do
you want
my answer then is the same as it is now
the number of beds is relevant
it's the number of children who are
incarcerated there that's relevant to me
and the treatment that those kids who
are there received that's what's
relevant
thank you Mr chair
seeing none will next hear from The
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record I'm Neil
Kirk I live in Ware and I'm representing
myself
as others who have spoken I've been
involved with this issue for at least
eight years
um and I can see it's finally coming to
I support
the amendment 767.
because it's a comprehensive
compromise
that re deals and resolves the sununu
issue
at least for the next decade
if you look at the co-sponsors and
sponsors of this bill
you'll see
these folks got together and they came
up with a comprehensive solution and
what does that do
first of all it builds the replacement
facility 12 to 18 18 beds but staffed
for 12.
appropriates 21.4 million dollars to do
this
secondly
because we don't want to repeat the
disastrous history of YDC and sununu
with respect to abuse situations it puts
in place a different philosophy a
different culture of how this operation
is going to be run you've heard it
mentioned trauma-informed care
the director is required to have certain
criteria and staff members are required
to implement certain criteria so that
the children will be receiving the care
that they need here and the staff
will not be the kind of Staff who
staffed YDC and sununu it will be a
different breed of person with different
training and that's very important we
don't want to repeat what's happened in
thirdly
this amendment puts into effect what
this house over years has decided is
important and it's been referred to in
the offenses for which
commitment detention at sununu are
further Limited
if you look at the charts that the
department is presented you'll see that
the census tsunu has dropped from 120 to
12 over the past five eight years and
that's largely not exclusively but
largely because of the statutory changes
because the philosophy of this house has
been children should receive treatment
in the community rather than in the
facility and it's only for the most
dangerous children
this comprehensive solution includes
that so there will be a further
reduction we believe in the number of
children
who are committed or detained in the
replacement facility
it's true that the current house has not
acted on this
but if you look back at the at the years
and the various children and fat youth
family law committee actions you'll see
that it's consistent in this area let's
put only the most difficult children
violent
children into this kind of a secure
facility
fourthly with respect to budgets there's
been some discussion today of those and
I think perhaps a reminder of how the
budget process works would be helpful
um
there are some
let's call them
guidelines about Staffing using some
sort of regional average
remember how and I'm sorry to have to
say this publicly but I think the P some
of the people testify need to hear this
I'm sure you folks don't
one of the things when you put something
in statute is that the department when
that It prepares its budget has to
follow the statute
so this committee is going to get a
budget for the replacement facility
based on the criteria in this bill
it won't be Priya
that was a red herring it will be
whatever standards are used now you've
also heard some information which
suggests these standards the average
don't make sense
and guess what that's the purpose of the
finance committee the department will
come in and present a budget that
represents what the statute requires
they will also because this committee
will ask them certainly division three
will will ask them well is this adequate
do you need more and then director
ribsum or his replacement if this
happens in the future
will come before you and say look our
facility has a relatively small number
of children
and these children are much more in need
of or much more dangerous perhaps than
in other facilities so our staffing
ratios cannot be the average and he will
make his case
and you will evaluate that
so the actual budget is not going to be
determined by the language here
this language only talks about what is
presented to this committee what the
governor will present in his budget what
the department will present in its
budget but you will make the ultimate
decision and I'm quite sure it's going
to reflect the reality that you can't
have a very small number of Staff
members for this these kinds of children
bottom line
this bill a comprehensive solution gets
this new new issue off the table
and resolved and for those folks like
representative Lynn who have a
particular issue
or the department which has some
concerns
as was mentioned there is House Bill 120
where these issues can be worked out and
any changes that that body feels are
necessary made
it's important that we take a major step
forward not just simply put into a place
a building but also the comprehensive
part that is this
767.
um
the issues that Advocates and lobbyists
raised can be handled in 120. but right
now you've got a very comprehensive
package that deserves to go forward
there were some technical corrections I
understand that need to be made but
beyond those this is really a solid
piece of legislation thank you Mr
chairman I'd be pleased to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you questions from the committee
members representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Kirk
I'm inclined to go along with your
position but I want to ask you about
possible other sort of negative
consequences of reducing the population
even more severely that it's already
been reduced
so in my mind one of the reasons we have
um commitment or incarceration or
whatever
is a consideration for the victims of
crimes
that
that we remove criminals from their
presence so that they will not be
further victimized
and is there any
do you think there's any concern here
that by having by releasing or not
committing
um
children who juveniles who don't who
commit crimes that we will expose the
public to further crimes and further
victim victimization thank you thank you
for that question representative McGuire
obviously that's a danger but that's a
danger at whatever level or whatever
standard you use for commitment
I think that that would be an important
factor taken into consideration when
children are committed to the sununu
center but it is certainly a risk and I
don't think this bill or any bill is
really going to be able to answer that
unless you want to take the position
which I know you don't and I certainly
don't that all children who commit
just about any kind of inappropriate
abusive activity should go to some sort
of facility like the sununu center which
had 144 beds at its maximum and I think
we've all agreed over the decades that
that is not the right place for most of
further questions representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I I don't want to
refer to it as 254 because that's a dead
bill from a previous era but I will
refer to zero seven six seven sections
eight and nine I believe your testimony
was that these items have not been heard
yet anywhere in the senate or in the
house and that this is the first time
this topic has been introduced
um would you would you believe that
both the current chairman and current
Vice chair representing our two great
parties have both independently and
collectively told me that they want
since they've retained HP 120 they want
to bring sections eight and nine into
their process because they're the policy
committee and this is Major policy would
you believe one that they've told me
that at and and two if you accept that
shouldn't we respect uh their opinion on
what's in their jurisdiction and what is
not
thank you for the question
representative Edwards I certainly
accept your characterization I have no
reason to to doubt it
um but I would say this
um
while the legislature each year is new
and each year can undo whatever has been
done in the past and there's no
certainty in that
this house as a body does have a history
and the history is 254 which is my
shorthand for sections eight and nine
it's most appropriate for this body
to recognize that history
included in this bill recognizing that
there is another bill House Bill 120
which is before that committee which
next year and they've retained it and
which next year they can work on it and
if and in fact they decide that these
things need to be changed and I my guess
is that because the house has been so
consistent over the years in doing this
that they will make some slight tweaks
but not change the basic policy that
this ha this body can go ahead with
in relative comfort that it is doing the
advancing the policy positions of this
house and its children and family law
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
answer
anything further from the committee
representative papavichi Miller
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I've you know we've listened to a lot of
testimony and personally I'm really
conflicted here because on one hand this
seems to be a generally a good direction
but there have been a lot of concerns
raised about the language and the
possible side effects and undesired
consequences of some of those
you know changes and you were saying
earlier that any concerns about this
could be addressed by the policy
committee my question to you is
you know why would this committee not
just focus on just the dollars and you
know hope that the policy committee will
include this language that we are
proposing in this amendment and fix you
know the possible concerns so basically
this is still contains policy this bill
and this is the finance committee so I'm
just trying to get your you know
take on this
thank you for the question that
certainly is one reasonable approach
but I'd point out to you that Amendment
804 and some of the other amendments
don't deal exclusively with the building
and its funding there's trauma-informed
care in these is that a policy decision
which we should wait and send back to uh
children and family law in 120 I think
the answer is no
I think it's important that we go ahead
with a comprehensive solution
and nobody is ever going to get it right
the first second or third time and we
will polish it next session with 120 and
the following session of the legislature
it will be further refined because we
can always make things better
and we
I think it's important that we take a
significant step now rather than try to
do this thing piecemeal because
piecemeal sometimes creates more
problems than a comprehensive solution
which can be amended in the future
further questions from committee
representative Petrie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question nice to see you
same here sir is there is there a danger
of uh these juveniles sidestepping the
juvenile just uh Juvenile Justice System
you see in uh on our Southern border
they use juveniles because they know
that they're
punishment or whatever
care whatever you want to call it is a
problem
uh thank you for that question
representative Petrie um
like you I've probably watched enough
television programs over the decades to
know that in police dramas it's a common
constant to use juveniles as various
a Bettors Lookouts
mules because everyone knows that no
matter what the state juveniles receive
different treatment
I don't think that that issue is
determinative of this bill
I think that issue will be here no
matter what happens
to the extent that these juveniles are
in fact extremely violent
then this bill deals with those and they
will be properly committed detained
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman and thank you members
there had been a plan if the time
permitted to do work session on this
obviously there isn't it's noon we have
a we're coming back here at one to exec
several bills
for full committee so let's have a lunch
if I may real quickly
um only because simple assault came up I
want everybody on the committee to
understand there's a 2006 New Hampshire
Supreme Court case
that was prosecuted by ayotte
and I don't remember the name of it but
it had to do with the definition of
simple assault and it was where one
attorney on leaving the courtroom pushed
another attorney with their thumb
against the shoulder
and that wrote that case went all the
way to the Supreme Court and simple
assault is taking your thumb and pushing
someone else's shoulder I I want us to
understand the legal definition when we
start talking about some of these things
because there is a there is a criminal
element in all of this
and that is not the same as some of the
serious crimes that we hear thank you
okay I will announce that the blue sheet
has two names both of them have have
testified before us one pro and one con
and there also will be some written
testimony that you can read that has
been submitted online uh we'll ask Mr
Ripple to uh see how many of those there
are and whether or not it's going to be
copied so have a good lunch we'll see
you all at one o'clock thank you very
much for your patience thank you for
tired of it it's not going to still come
join yourself aren't you sure would you
yeah
agreement all right committee members
each of you has received a packet of
bills
you may not have all the same bills as
you should have the bills already in
your possession for your division
the bills you have in this packet are
for the divisions that you're not in
because you need to be familiar with
those when we exec them
we have a deadline on
49 House Bill 49 tomorrow
so since we had a work session and it
went right up to lunchtime and I decided
to stop then and have lunch
now I'd like to proceed forward and try
to get something passed on 49 since it
has a deadline
so we had discussions this morning on
our on our Amendment 767
and there were some weaknesses and I'm
going to discuss those with two other
chairmen the chairman of Judiciary who's
here representative Lynn and the
chairman of Children and Family Law
representative Pearson so first I'll
allow representative Lynn to briefly
introduce the amendment and if we've
heard a lot about what it's going to do
you don't have to go into the too much
detail I hope
uh thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee and what I I guess I try
to make is really very brief because I
would just be repeating what I said
earlier the amendment that I have
proposed and which I guess would would
need to be introduced by a member of
this committee
um which I'm not on but uh it's eight
it's 892 and and what I would say is
is exactly the same literally word for
word as 767 except that
it adds it adds a new
section eight
to the bill and then renumbers what
comes after Section 8 in 767 renumbers
it so that there's when you get to the
end there's one more section and in the
section eight
which is what's new
it just makes a two-word change it it it
it deals with
RSA 169 b14 which is a section of the
Juvenile Justice Act
that that talks that deals with
detention
and it basically adds the words
uh quote or 169 B colon 19 1
parenthesis M close parenthesis and the
purpose of that is simply to make to
make it clear
since you're since you're creating the
section m in 19 as an as another basis
for
commitment I think you need to make the
change to 14 so that it's consistent so
that
you know it I I completely agree with
the idea that somebody shouldn't be able
to be detained for an offense that they
couldn't be committed for but since
you're now saying well you can be
committed for M it seems to me you have
to change 14 to be consistent so I guess
what I would say is that that's that's
really the the sum and substance of the
amendment and I'm happy to answer any
questions
where is their Chief questioner
oh there he is
[Music]
all right
there were some thought earlier that
and the reason we had a a
specific hearing for the previous
um amendment was because it was getting
into policy areas and it was a little
non-germaine to the what the original
House Bill 49 was now we know you have
House Bill 120 and I believe you have
retained it with the thought that if
there was something that needed more
work on what we might pass here today
because we're on a cup on a deadline
that you could put it in 120
which you've retained and then bring it
back in January does that sound
reasonable
Amanda if you want to send us Amendment
767 our way to we'll be working on this
uh individuals have already been so
excited about it that they're starting
to ask questions all over the place and
uh I don't think they're going to do it
what's on our summer vacation list but
yeah we would be very happy to take up
uh 120 with this 767 Amendment or
anything else you care to send us this
policy
thank you that that helps us try to get
49 out of here today so it can make the
the deadline
all right division three chair how do
I I think we have zero zero seven six
seven in in in in the Lynn amendment I I
think they are slightly competing uh I I
would like to move actually uh that we
accept the Lynn Amendment
um and I I
that motion would need to be seconded
representative emmerich seconds the
motion to pass Amendment zero eight nine
two H for house bill 49.
further questions from many committee
members
I appreciate that there are not
so everybody seems to understand what
um representative Lynn made the changes
to this amendment that he spoke of this
morning
as you heard we also have another shot
at 120 so anything that we Overlook now
hopefully can go forward in 120 and be
Joe ripsom director dcyf
and I do appreciate representative Lynn
was trying to do with this amendment in
terms of reconciling the detention and
the commitment changes my biggest
concern in the immediate term is that if
eight and nine become law and become
applicable before 120 fixes them right
because for some reason it seems like
we're deciding to move the policy
through here and then fix it later
instead of actually fixing the policy
before we move it through
if those become law immediately they
will undermine SB 94 which is wildly
successful in a national model today
and that would be devastating how will
they underline it because you will
change the incentives of law enforcement
to be willing to accept our
recommendations to not send kids to
court
what will happen instead is law
enforcement will be afraid that if they
don't stack up three prior charges for
things like domestic violence and simple
assault that those kids will then not be
able to be eligible to be detained in
case it becomes necessary in the future
and will be more likely to say we're
going to charge these kids each time
instead of letting them be deferred
which is what's happening today with
wild success under SB 94 the other thing
that will happen that happens today with
I think great success is kids who are
currently on probation
they typically don't get new charges
they just get violated on probation and
the court brings them back you know
reads them the riot act whatever but
they don't get new charges with this
change you're going to incentivize that
those kids stack up new charges so
you've really changed the process by
which folks are going to have to make
their decision about whether or not to
bring charges and the entire system
we've built in the past couple years is
not just around keeping kids out of sysc
it's about keeping them out of the
system as a whole not bringing charges
at all and what this is going to do is
incentivize the exact opposite behavior
from law enforcement and prosecutors
when they're worried about maintaining
Community safety
okay and we're gonna let Judge Lynn
respond my experience was when we asked
the
County attorney to give us a list of of
the cases they had virtually everybody
that was arrested had five charges
against them I was always resisting
arrest attempting to leave and all this
kind of thing nobody ever got arrested
for one thing and and if it was if you
had if they had any drugs it was intent
to distribute possession all those
things everything got added on to it so
I don't know is that would be any
different when they arrest because it
seems to be a pattern anyway so this
this this requires that there'd be three
separate incidents not multiple charges
on a single incident right so that's
actually not not the circumstance that
we're talking about you could have three
separate incidents of 10 charges each
but they'd have to be three separate
incidents in here it's not just one
incident with multiple charges and it's
three separate incidents that have been
proven or adjudicated within a 12-month
period so again I don't think it
meaningfully changes the census of who's
at sysc because when we look at that the
kids who actually get detained and
committed have dozens unfortunately a
prior incidence but what it will do is
meaningfully impact the decisions that
prosecutors in law enforcement make on
the ground about whether to bring a
charge in the first place and that's
what I'm really worried about more than
anything
thank you uh representative Lynn yeah uh
Mr chairman members committee I guess I
I just wanted to say so because I don't
want the committee to misinterpret my
position
when when I offered Amendment 892 with
the change that I explained a moment ago
I did that after discussions with
representative erf
because because basically what what I
said to him and what I say to this
committee is if you're gonna Inc if
you're gonna include
the the the changes that are now in
sections eight and nine of of amendment
767. if you're gonna do that
then I hope you will consider my
Amendment instead which which makes the
change to section 14. but
that's that's really sort of my fallback
position if you will I agree completely
with with Mr ribson but I I think that
the best if the committee wants to know
what the best thing to do here at least
from my perspective it would be just
don't take that 254 language the eight
nine
Section 8 and 9 out of this completely
don't deal with that at all let that go
to child and family I think that would
be the ideal resolution that's what I
would suggest suggest but that's in in
your Amendment though no it isn't
it's not 254 language
my language includes the the 254
language that is was in representative
Earth's and representative holds
Amendment and it added that one other
section I talked about before I guess as
I said my position I guess my view is if
you're gonna
you know pass the 254 as part of this
bill then please include
you know please do it via my Amendment
rather than the 767 Amendment but I
would prefer I would think the better
thing to do is not not pass not include
the 267 uh the 254 language at all
so Mr chair I representative if I may I
would like to change my motion and my
motion would be and I hopefully the
person who seconded will support this I
would like to have both zero eight nine
two zero seven six seven both retained
so that children and family law can
consider it as part of HB 120. does this
affect the funding going forward
there are two other amendments before us
my amendments that both address the
funding and the operations they're both
good bills that get us extremely close
to sb1
are they simply uh providing the the
wherewithal the move forward on the
construction and funded and pick the
spot uh yes sir one of the two
amendments is very short and very
narrowly tailored to to that the other
one incorporates all of the operational
aspects that the community has been
lobbying for for two years on having a
trauma-informed therapeutic based model
do we have that Amendment before us we
have both and they were both basically
introduced last time we heard 49 a week
one one is zero eight zero four
and the other
if the committee wants to just do
something short and simple is zero seven
three eight
between the two I I prefer zero eight
zero four because it gets us closer to
being at sb1 but if all we want to do is
to get this onto the floor and have the
money taken care of then zero seven
okay we need a second on that so your
motion was to retain both 767 and air
and I don't care if we do them one at a
time or together but yes retain zero
all right since we started with zero
seven six seven
they're going to retain amendments if
it would be easier if you withdrew that
what would be a superior motion I I
don't I really don't want the committee
to to to pass these out of the committee
today because there are better
Alternatives and the children and family
law has not yet heard these policy
issues
then I would suggest you withdraw the
amendments
representative McGuire I would suggest
you just move the amendment that you
prefer
the the one I prefer is
zero eight zero four that we haven't
heard for from about in a week
both
the other two are were current today but
I did introduce zero eight zero four a
week ago
and for anyone who's been following this
and when they read this this is this is
essentially the completion of the
Senate's sb1 that passed 24 to nothing
and zero eight zero four I think I can
say ex that all of the activists here
have looked at it and have supported it
and I I think the department has
supported zero eight zero four the
governor's office has called me and said
it the Senate voted 24 to nothing so I
the preponderance is that we really
ought to just pass zero eight zero four
uh in an earlier time when we looked at
0804 and representative hole brought up
the fact that he thought the uh that
might be a challenge on using arpa funds
so I forwarded that question that's
about a week and a half ago to the
attorney general and said what do you
think of this is it true that Maine has
been sued for trying to use arpa funds
to fix a jail he wrote back and said he
found no evidence of that he said they
had been a story and someone had written
a letter to the paper saying we
shouldn't do this but he said there was
no formal thing filed and he and the uh
attorney for the Opera funds had both
reviewed the
proposal so that's again another reason
why we have to move forward while These
arpa funds have to be committed
within the year and then the bill the
building has to be built within by 2026
I believe is that what do you recall
yes that's correct so there is there is
a reason to move forward on something
that they can begin to go and request
These arpa funds so a short and sweet
one would be a good way to go
um
so now the amendment the motion we have
before us is to accept zero eight zero
four Amendment which will be followed by
a not to pass as amended Mr chairman
amendment 0804 was that was introduced
in the division three
it was well
I I thought it was also in full Finance
it was in full Finance
was introduced in full Finance it was
introduced to full Finance okay
yes uh yeah I want to get the procedures
right don't we that's right because I
don't want to don't want to hold on
something I've never never seen or has
never been introduced yes that's that's
and I have notes on it that's where
representative hole brought up the fact
about
is there going to be a challenge to
using arpa funds so I run that by the
Attorney General at the request of the
committee he's come back and said not to
worry that the arpa attorney and himself
think it's it easily satisfies the arpa
requirements so that's an important way
to get this
um funding going so we can start to
thank you Mr chairman I don't know
whether the question is appropriate at
this time or not but I I'm just trying
to understand whether
uh for example
we would maybe be better off if we just
uh looked at the 892 Amendment and just
change the effective date to something
like July 1st 2024 to address director
ribsam's concerns that the changes may
be effective immediately while at the
same time giving a bit of time you know
giving a clear idea of what we want and
letting the department the appropriate
policy committee work on this
the director already had concerns with
what it would do to to
incarcerating people that were brought
before if it becomes applicable
immediately you know what if it would be
you know in effect 60 days after the
passage I was asking about a July 1st
2024 effective that would require
further amendments which I'm trying to
get the process moving
representative Edwards I I don't want to
put words in Mr ribson's mouth but I
believe he's on record as already
supporting
um my Amendment from last week zero
eight zero four and that he's shown up
here today to oppose zero seven six
seven and that when you add
representative Lynn's concern I think by
extension he would probably oppose zero
eight nine two so of these three there's
one that you and are currently in favor
zero eight zero four is that true that's
so we have a motion
motion is to adopt Amendment 0804
does everyone understand that and have
it before them
further questions
representative walner yes I I just want
to say that I'm going to vote
um no on this
because for me the most important piece
in zero seven six seven
was the area where we limited what
children would be placed in the sununu
center or the new sununu center and I'm
just gonna I'm I'm not gonna talk for
very long I'm going to be really short
but I would like to bring everyone's
attention to the first
um five lines of the bill
of all of the bills every bill that
we've seen so far has these lines and
the line says
placement in Corrections settings can be
harmful to children
and lead to increased delinquency and
adult criminal Behavior
it should therefore be reserved for
those circumstances in which the safety
of the child and of the community
requires such confinement
that to me sums it up we need to be sure
that this is limited to just the
children who need this level of care
and that is the reason I will be voting
no on this amendment
it has that language that you just
quoted
but it does not have the sections in the
bill
does not have the sections around
limiting who can be placed at the sununu
center which is on page six
of
0767 from line 17. down through line 32.
the motion before us is zero eight zero
four right and that's the one I'm going
to vote against thank you
representative grassy yeah I mean I
thought would the discussion we just had
said that that decision would be going
to Children and Family Law
and that they would look at that and
bring something in in January basically
to to address that issue and that that
was probably the more appropriate place
representative
so
I'm a little confused I don't want to
discuss 767 yet since it's not
apparently up for discussion at this
point although I thought that's where
we're going to start today
but
I'm going to vote against this as well
the points that were made this morning
are essentially the ones that have been
made all along in this process which
have been the hold up here
it's not enough just to build a new
building
that's the whole idea behind 767 it
brings together the new building along
with an approach that will over time
reduce the census at sununu and more
importantly
Give Kids the opportunity not to be in
sununu but that might otherwise be there
I understand there's disagreements
between the director and other people
both in the community and out of the
community and I would like the chance to
discuss the details of sections eight
and nine but we can do that later I just
want to say at this point I'm voting
against
084 and I'll also point out that 08 Ford
doesn't allocate any funding so I'm not
exactly sure how that's going to help
further discussion representative hole
thank you chairman
um I'm going to take a brief minute and
go back in history because this is
clearly an issue that is difficult to
resolve to approve July 13 1855 at a
meeting of the governor and Council July
20th 1855 honorable Frederick Smith of
Manchester honorable Matthew Harvey of
Concord and Jose Eaton a squire of New
Ipswich who are appointed to
Commissioners agreeably for the
provisions and the purposes named in the
foregoing resolution I will skip to the
resolution this is about the design and
installation of a Reformation of
juvenile and female offenders who have
committed the offenses against the state
this is part of what was the deed to
donate the property to the state
why I bring this up is it is to take the
and I quote it is to take those who
would otherwise fill our jails and state
prison and place them in an institution
where they will both be morally and
physically trained away from the vicious
influence of hardened convicted
it says sorry hardened convict where
they will receive the advantages of a
common school education where all
reasonable efforts will be made to
prepare them to earn an honest
livelihood honorable industry and in
some trade or other respectable
employment I think the appointment is
we've been wrestling with this for 170
years almost at this point this is a
difficult task but I I believe there is
a group here who wants to see
a change in our statutes so that we are
not sending someone there inadvertently
and I know that everybody in this room
cares about the kids we all have a
common goal here
but when I read this document that was
handed this morning to us about the way
you could end up in the sununu center I
could imagine
easily okay where a trafficked teenage
girl ends up with three or four of
offenses on this and when we do the the
tally at the end of the day
with an overzealous prosecutor and the
wrong judge
she might end up at the sununa center
and that is not the place to send a
female a young female person
that would be the wrong possible the
worst thing you could do to them
I believe we all want to do the right
thing I believe we all want to make sure
that the right kids are taken care of
and some of them need compassion and
love as we heard this morning from
former representative Blancher when he
heard I love you
I pardon for those who
um
I'm going to share a piece of scripture
and it's it and it's
it's out of the Gospel of John and it
has to do with the adulterous woman and
I say this because
he shows the mercy and care that's
necessary for someone who has been
caught by the law back then adultery was
a capital punishment offense and he said
let he who is without the first sin cast
the first stone why do I say that
because it was that love and mercy that
changed her life we need to do the same
I cannot support this amendment the
changes that are in 767 and subsequently
in 92 I think okay
um are the next step to make this work
are we ready for a vote on 804 that's
I
I just want to support the motion I'm
going to vote yay on this I I want to
point out that the despite the
hypothetical uh example of the sex
trafficking girl we have no testimony to
suggest that's ever really happened it
it it and I don't think any of us would
want it to but I think fortunately
reality is that it probably hasn't we
heard from represent or on the honorable
Cody Belanger who basically uh was
opposed to
767 and uh and I and I and from talking
to him I believe he would support zero
eight zero four this bill has been
worked for two years we have all of The
Advocates supporting zero eight zero
four we have the department supporting
zero eight zero four the Senate passed
what the elements of zero eight zero
four and sb1 24-9 nothing the governor's
office is in favor of zero eight zero
four so I so despite kind of this last
minute let's change it and delay it and
finance we've heard from the chairman of
Children and Family Law who said Give me
you're tired you're weak your your
huddled masses around the the criminal
code and send them over to Children and
Family Law so that they can hear it with
their experience and with their
jurisdiction so I would ask you to let's
just stay the course let's complete the
task let's vote in favor of zero eight
zero four thank you
further discussion from committee seeing
none the clerk will call the roll the
motion is to adopt zero eight zero four
Amendment clerk will call the roll
representative Earth
no
yes
fancy stuff
no I hit my I was too rosellos here
uh representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative cambrose
yes
representative
there's an inogram
no
no Arizona leishman
yes
there's one of uh hatches there's a
hatch here
Arizona Heath
no
version of Murray
version of evil
no
original trolorski
Mr chairman of vote is 11 years 13. oh
I'm sorry yeah I normally very well
although yes
if you vote in the ass okay so that
against
wait a minute wait what oh I'm grassy
let me let me get the pawn Street
representative Hull uh I move 767.
and would like to speak to my my motion
or we haven't got it I don't think we
completed a vote
yeah that's we I gotta be retrained
13 um
yeah no was 12 13. 12 14 13 against the
motion fails represent whole is
recognized for emotion sure I move 767
and I and and I respect um
representative Lynn and that one comment
and I am not a legal expert so it may be
an important change
um and I I Look to Him
regarding that one additional line but I
know it hasn't been discussed in the
committee
um like the the whole 767 Amendment if
we move this I do know that the good
news is even if it passes the house as
is there's the Senate this doesn't
become law Tomorrow there's lots of
times to make a small one-line tweak
along the way if we move 767 it gets
from this house finance onto the floor
headed to the Senate which is the right
is there a second representative Earth
seconds at the motion before us is for
zero zero seven six seven which we all
heard this morning
is there any further discussion from the
members of the committee
representative Leachman thanks Mr
chairman again I
uh I'm not entirely familiar with all
the division three material that we see
but I guess I'm concerned when I've
heard that the advocates
have been supportive of the amendment
that we just voted on and defeated and
that the department is in favor of the
motion that we just defeated so I'm
really concerned where this is going and
maybe somebody could speak to me
why The Advocates were in favor of the
last bill or maybe they're not in favor
of this one but I'm a little concerned
when The Advocates have been so loud and
clear of their support
of the bill we just defeated and along
with the department so I'm a little
concerned about that Mr chairman
representative Hull sure if I I'm
willing to take my best to summarize
several of The Advocates came in on page
two
um lines 24 and 25 in particular right
and this has to do with the concerns
that were raised regarding the Staffing
at the center several of them mentioned
the Prius standards which is the prison
rape elimination act standards I think
all of those who looked into this who
were part of crafting this amendment
weren't looking for ratios at one to
eight we heard discussions where's my
notes we heard discussions by some of
the outside that they have ratios of two
to twelve in other places one even said
one to three I think there's the reality
is that the children that are in this
Center are going to require a certain
level of attention that attention is
greater than one to one when we were
just discussing this amendment we were
trying to be at one to four
I did some research and in hb1 of
2016-2017 which was when director ripson
would have been operating in the budget
that he would have come into there was
90 staff members allocated the sununu
center for 70 kids we have 87 in the
current budget request I think the goal
of this was to try and make sure the
facility was designed to be at the four
or five members per child there not at
eight
Mr ribson shook his head I'll ask him to
what his comment would be about the
Staffing
I started here October 2017 I wasn't
part of that budget process but when I
came here there was well over 100 staff
at sysc so I'm not quite sure what that
budget process was or what the language
was it's being talked about there but
there were well over 100 staff at that
point at this point I think it's
somewhere in the mid 80s that includes
an awful lot of staff that we say we
would no longer need if we were to be
able to co-locate and be able to share
services like maintenance laundry
nutrition etc etc etc
thank you
representative erf do you want to
comment
any of the other people that uh that did
not
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman I'll I'll be brief I'm I'm
pretty disappointed with what we're
doing right now and what it feels like
this committee is doing I think we're
all operating under the correct
assumption that we do have to build and
construct a new new Youth Services
Center or a Youth Detention Facility
Juvenile Detention whatever we want to
call it we have to do it and we
recognize that to use the bill to
construct the new center as leverage for
policy changes that should be made in
the policy committee is where we should
be focused on we should be tasked with
the financing of the new facility
that is our job as the finance committee
allow the policy committees that are new
since the last time this language was
discussed to work out among themselves
the criminal codes and the ways that
people get to the sununu center the
youth detention center and let us be
tasked with building the thing that's
our job and I I we're not Washington DC
we shouldn't be leveraging must pass
legislation in order to pass in other
policy priorities that haven't gone
through the current year policy
committee uh so I'm going to vote no on
this amendment there's another amendment
that is more watered down that if we can
pass it we can actually make sure the
construction gets handled and let's let
other members of the legislature in the
policy area for criminal activity and
for children and family law to focus on
the statutes that are sending people to
the center and let us focus on what we
need to do to build the new facility so
I'm voting no on this I'd love to vote
Yes on another amendment and get this
bill out of here today but we should not
use
honestly bad objects and bad politics to
lever
different policy positions onto this
bill that haven't been fully vetted by
the appropriate policy committee thank
you
representative erf
thank you Mr chair so I had hope not to
go down this road I thought we'd be
discussing the bills but it seems that
what's really important to folks here is
that this is supposedly we're rushing
this through at the last minute
we need a little history of what's going
on this term first of all if you look at
this bill the actual underlying Bill
we're talking about today it's a bill to
extend the closing date of the sununu
center and allocate the funds to pay for
the sunundo center through the rest of
this fiscal year
that's a bill that should have been
rushed through because what was the
deadline we had to meet
we had to stop the sununa center being
closed in March did we rush this bill
through
no no we didn't
what happened and what happened behind
the scenes unbeknownst to most of us
here certainly most of us or I should
say maybe just some of us in division
three the Senate put together a bill not
only to extend the dates and fund for
the FY 23 period of time
but also to do a whole massive amount of
other things and they rushed that bill
through over in the Senate and in fact
that 24 to nothing vote was actually not
a 24 to nothing vote because that was an
illegitimate vote that was held in the
original
um or committee dual committee meetings
like we held here
one that came over here to the house it
was rushed through children and family
law I didn't even learn about it until
the day literally the day of the hearing
in children and family law and there
were folks in children and family law
that I spoke with that were kind of
surprised that it went through as
quickly as it did so the process has
been rushed that's absolutely true
then it came here to finance and we were
actually able to to take out most of it
and leave in there the critical pieces
the date change the funding and finding
a site for the facility and starting the
design process all of that is already in
process and all of that is going to take
time nothing we're doing here today is
going to impact the construction of the
sununa center it that couldn't be
handled in another month or two months
as far as the whole process is concerned
so I'm frustrated as well absolutely for
sure but this language has been vetted
through this house last year were there
issues with it as Judge Lynn has pointed
out absolutely and as Judge Lynn has
pointed out he was very gracious in
working with me to help improve it to
the point where it's at now we do have a
minor disagreement I'd call it a minor
agreement he'd call it major regarding
one piece that he asked about but we
have been working through this in in the
most in the most effective way we can
given the constraints this is an early
bill this has to be out tomorrow
whereas it doesn't need to be this issue
does not need to be resolved tomorrow we
have the budget the normal process that
Finance runs and you'll see that through
all the rest of the bills we're going to
exec today
is bills that are going to be that have
money they get they get held retained
and they get put into the budget this
process this particular process has been
completely out of the ordinary
as far as the way Finance works and the
way bills normally proceed through the
entire process so I am voting in favor
of this because I do think it is the
seven I'm sorry I'm voting yes the favor
of 767 because I do think you need to
put together both it's not just about
building a new facility this new
facility will not be built we started we
allocated funding appropriate funding
for the forensic prison forensic
whatever that we call it it's like
psychiatric whatever it is
four years ago and it still hasn't
broken ground so
let's be realistic in terms of time
frames what we're talking about today is
trying to rush what we were talking
about in the last vote we took was
trying to rush things through
what we're suggesting is a better
alternative which will do all the things
that one does and in fact it's based on
the original Amendment the 767 is based
on the original amendment that was voted
out of our division three slash division
one meeting several weeks ago which
you'll note you didn't see here today
for whatever reason so I am voting in
favor of this and I think it is the
right thing to do for the children
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman yeah I'm I'm not
going to vote for this amendment because
but the amendment I would vote for is
892.
that's different by two three four words
and it fixes a serious problem in the
amendment that we have in front of us
the the amendment we have in front of us
has a different set of crimes for
commission
to commit someone or to detain them that
makes no sense
um zero eight nine two h
it's the same set of crimes for which
someone can be committed and detained
right otherwise they're identical so why
should we pass something we know right
now is flawed when right on the table in
front of us is something that's less
flawed you know which I would vote for
representative
thank you I just wanted to state that
because of the concerns expressed by
director ibsum by the because of the
impact of this immediately I'm not gonna
support this amendment even though I do
like it in principle but I'm concerned
about the immediate effective date so uh
I'm sorry I just
just a quick one the the the the section
in here sections eight and nine it's
without doubt been in testimony that
these were the very first times those
two sections have been heard anywhere in
the house anywhere in the Senate since
this calendar year began and this
legislature began so so this is brand
new stuff this is the example of rushing
things through that could very well at
the request of the chairman of Children
and Family Law go over to them for the
policy issue so so I'm going to vote
against
um
767 and I hope you will as well I might
be inclined to vote for zero eight nine
two as an alternative to this horrible
alternative
further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on the motion to adopt Amendment zero
seven six seven
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes
representative McGuire no
Rosanna Petri votes no
representative Emrick oh
representative Griffin oh
representative Mooney no
representative Edwards no
representative Bean
representative Campbell's
no
Representative no
representative norgren yeah
there's an aggressing yes
Rosanna Murray
yes
there's no evil
here's John trollerski
yes
here's our hicken Phillips yes
The Proposal dies
um
representative McGuire's Rick is
is recognized for it in motion all right
I'll move Amendment zero eight nine two
h
do we need further discussion on this
amendment
Mr chair I I would just say that um I I
still have this a skinny version of this
whole thing and represented in zero
seven three eight and I hope I can make
any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
to adopt Amendment
0892h on HB 49.
thank you Mr chairman representative yes
president McGuire yes
representative
Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney no
representative Edwards
I said I would so yes I hate it though
representative Bean
there's a hole
yes
representative gambrells
representative papavichi Mueller yes
representative Waller yes
representative yes
president releaseman
yes
wait
you win all right I want it my way I
mean it's I have a story I'll tell you
that let me know eliminate that
the answer the answer to your question
is yes thank you
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
yes
version of Stringham no
Mr chairman of vote is 21-4 in the
affirmative
we have adopted Amendment zero eight
nine two h
I'm ready to
accept emotion for House Bill 49 ought
to pass as amended by Amendment 0892h
representative Weiler yes there's still
an amendment that's never received a
vote that has received the discussion by
this committee zero seven three eight
this is a skinny Bill all it does is it
gets us out of the policy issues
entirely does an appropriation and
designate who makes the decision on the
final site selection and size it also
uses the arpa money so I I what what
should we do with zero seven three eight
it's not received a vote in the
committee
has it had a discussion before the full
committee I attempted that last week and
I was stopped because there was a
non-germaine amendment that we were
supposed to discuss today and we've done
that I don't have a copy of that
Amendment you said zero eight zero seven
three eight I do have a copy of it it's
just it's just basically a front page
with a tiny amount on the back all this
does is it has Finance do Finance stuff
it appropriates the money gets us out of
the policy issue we've heard that
chairman of uh children and family law
say please let them do policy so this is
us where we can just do the money and
do you understand this would cancel the
one that just passed with a fairly good
vote
I I still wanted to get a vote because I
I guess we can do that representative
hole
um
further discussion from the committee
is everyone familiar with it
representative Murray
will you just restate and be clear that
if we pass this amendment the previous
Amendment 892 would be voided
yes
I I understood that there is a
possibility that OLS can can merge when
they're too accepted amendments or or in
this if there are two accepted bills
from the house floor that contradict
each other a little bit I understood OLS
can do some merger is there no merging
of
depends on what the motion is for once
we have established amendments what
ought to pass has amended States
place
thank you Mr chairman I believe to
answer representative Edwards question
in amendment number
0738 line five it does say the bill
replaces all after the enacting Clause
to me that's a replacement Amendment
so though some amendments could be
compatible this does not appear to be a
compatible one it appears to be a
replacement thank you Mr chair thank you
I'd apologize I've known you longer than
Murray I I I know why I called you a
Mooney I accept uh representative
Mooney's explanation
I need a
second first first answer
all right did you make a motion to adopt
Amendment zero seven three eight I make
a motion to adopt zero seven three eight
representative Griffin seconds
any further discussion from the
committee
seeing none the clerk will call the role
to adopt
0738h and as has been stated this will
replace the one we just adopted thank
you
thank you Mr chairman
all right let me get the
10738h uh representative Earth now
representative McGuire no
original Petri votes no
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
Arizona Edwards
yes
representative hole no
representative Sweeney yes
representative Kimbrell's
no
represent a puppy molar no
Representative no
representative Leachman no
representative Buco no
Hewitt
that's that tough one my brain just
didn't want to wrap around that
representative Heath no
president Murray no
version of evil
yes
president solorski
no
version of hicken Phillips no
Mr chairman the vote is 8-17 and the
motion fails
ocean fails I'll entertain a motion
to uh
ought to pass
or rtpa
ought to pass for House Bill 49 as
amended in Amendment 0892h
so I moved motion is there a second
second by representative Hull
further discussion from the committee
oh well that was Earth it was Earth and
hold
EXC
okay thank you Mr chairman
um representative Earth
yes
Arizona McGuire
president Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes
Arizona Mooney
no
representative Edwards
yes
in a bean
yes represent a hole
yes
there's no Sweeney no
representative Kimbrell's yes
there's a papa Vici mower yes
representative Wallner
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
yes
representative grassy yes
uh Hewitt
yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
version of evil yes
representative
yes
president haken Phillips
was that a yes I'm sorry
thank you
representative Stringham yes
okay we have adopted
um
House Bill 49 as amended by amendment
number 0892h thank you all for your
consideration Mr chair you need to have
that report written soon representative
hole I believe we have 26 here unless
someone left during the voting
oh no thank you
25 is is the total membership I guess
everybody's here
those people
okay
chicken's eyes
all right now we move to the to the
bills that we are executing today uh you
should all have this sheet before you
and we'll start and and we have some of
the reports written the others I hope
will be written before you leave today
because this has to go into the clerk
soon okay
so
if I'll recognize uh representative
leishman to lead us for the bills that
division one has dealt with
thank you very much Mr chairman I'd like
to recognize representative McGuire who
moved the passage of house bill 50 as
amended yes I'd like to move amen
Amendment
0997 H to house bill 50.
self
it might might
thank you
is there any objecting to doing this by
a show of hands
I'd like to have our own confidence Jim
all right request a roll call for
adopting amendment 0-997 should I
explain the situation or did anybody
second the roll call that's our our
second EU all right
we'll have a roll call who's second in
the motion
Griffin thank you representative
representative Maguire wants to speak
well I I just I can explain what's going
on with this amendment if anybody has
any question about it
um this original bill
did something that was in the budget
last time which was to have the state
pay out of General funds seven and a
half percent of the town's expenses for
teachers fire and and police of the
retirement part of their expenses
and
um we tried the the bill itself uh
deadlocked in our division four to four
as is
so we proposed this amendment
um which was unanimous to instead uh
instead take a similar amount of money
in this case 50 million dollars and put
it into the against the unfunded
liability of the retirement system and
that has the effect of saving uh money
to similar effects saving money to towns
and and uh other employers but it does
it slowly over time rather than all at
once just in this biennium now you
should all have a kind of a gray looking
this is the analysis of this amendment
and so you can see that
um spending 50 million dollars in this
way will save the uh towns and and other
employers a hundred and five million
dollars over the next
um 20 years
all right due to the magic of compound
interest so so this is the
fix the problem slowly sort of amendment
rather than um yeah
rather than dump some money all at once
and still have a serious problem next
time so
um
yeah so 50 million dollars cost now
gains us 105 over the over the decades
um now my particular plan for this
amendment and I would invite comment is
to treat it sort of Senate style and
that is this is a big change from the
way the original bill was written it's
the same subject but it's so I think
it's completely germane but it's it's a
change of tactics sort of and um so I
would like this committee to vote this
ought to pass send it to the house floor
hopefully get an off to pass there and
then ask to table it
um and then put it in to our budget
right so so do it sort of Senate style
where we pass the policy and then that
will be the house the house policy
um and then but it will it will be in
the budget we will not pass the bill on
further discussion on the amendment
clerk will call call a role on adopting
Amendment 0997
to house bill 50.
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes
president McGuire yes president Petrie
votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Griffin did I call you
thank you
thank you I just I just trying to fool
you
representative Edwards yes
there's a bean
representative hole
yes
representative Sweeney yes
Arizona kimbrells yes representative
mower yes
representative Auburn no
representative leishman
yes
Hewitt
the original Heath yes
representative Murray
yes
represent of evil yes
representative
no
representative Phillips no
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler
Mr chandel vote is 19-6
in a favor
emotion the amendment is adopted 0997
recognize representative McGuire from
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
Motion in a second motion by McGuire
seconded by Griffin
ought to pass as amended by Amendment
uh representative Heath you got your mic
on
okay
so you know no other discussion clerical
collar roll onto pass has amended house
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes
representative McGuire yes there's no
Petri votes yes representative Griffin
yes
what do I do boy all right
representative uh Emrick yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes
Arizona bean
represent a hole
yes
Arizona Sweeney yes
represent cameras yes
representative papovichi Mueller yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
there's an abuco
yes
grassy yes
it was on do it yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
yes
there's going to string them yes
and representative Weiler yes
yes Mr chairman of vote is 25-0
in favor okay uh we have adopted house
bill 50 as amended by
Amendment 0997.
uh back to representative leishman for
the next one
thank you Mr chairman the next one we
have is House Bill 311. many of you
this is moved to retained by
representative hatch who can
unfortunately be with us today but
that appropriation amount is in the
governor's budget that's the reason for
our retaining
I'll second
motion by leashman second by McGuire to
retain House Bill 311 is there any
further discussion
seeing none the clerical collar role on
retain for House Bill 311 and no report
representative erf yes
Reverend Richard McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes sir
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
representative Hull
yes
representative Sweeney yes
Arizona cameras yes representative
Mueller yes
she's absent okay
representative wait a minute here she is
oh
representative all right I'll wait to
look
representative
representative the motion is to retain
representative Leachman yes
there's an abuco yes
representative grassy yes
representative view it yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
president haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman of vote is 25-0 in favor
okay we have adopted the retained motion
on House Bill 311 representative
leishman
thank you Mr chairman the next on our
latest House Bill
384 relative to the new legislative
parking garage I'd like to recognize
representative evil
thank you Mr chairman so you have before
you
um Amendment uh zero four two H to HB
384 I'd like to move passage of that
thank you representative and can you
explain what the amendment yes I will so
now I'll speak to my motion okay there
were several changes we we worked on
this quite a bit within the within the
division there are several changes to
the original Bill the first change is
that the amount of 25 million dollars is
going to be appropriated to the
Department of administrative Services
instead of to the legislative branch the
division was persuaded that from an
oversight and experiential standpoint
Das was the appropriate
um agency to to appropriate the money to
and to oversee the project and there was
consensus on that uh within the division
the second change that was made was that
um
22.5 million dollars will be coming out
of the general fund but 2.5 million
dollars will be coming out of the
legislative account so that the
legislature uses some of the money that
we appropriate to it to construct its
garage so that was the second point I
would just add here that in the
governor's budget he appropriated
um 15 million dollars so this is 10
million more than uh what the governor
appropriated
minus the 2.5 that is coming out of the
legislative account so we thought that
was a good uh change the next thing
we're doing I don't know how many of you
are familiar with what we call the
capital budget overview committee the
way things uh had usually been capital
projects went through the capital budget
and then they would go for oversight to
the capital budget overview committee
the way things have been going now
sometimes we have capital projects going
through the capital budget sometimes as
we're seeing today we have projects
going that are capital infrastructure
projects going through the operating
budget we all agreed and so did the uh
commissioner Arling house that
regardless of how they were funded they
still deserved oversight and so there
was great consensus on our committee
that we should convert that that
overview committee to the capital
project overview committee so that's
what we did the next thing that we did
was we created a joint legislative
parking garage oversight commission to
specifically oversee this rather large
project which is going to involve the
construction of the parking garage
raising the doj building and also
raising the much beloved store street
parking garage
and what you'll see here you can see
with who the appointees are a couple of
important important points here is that
the president of the Senate and the
Speaker of the House in addition to
having a senator and a representative
they can also designate someone who can
be a public member who might bring more
experience to the um
to the project
and
that is it there is a reporting
requirement you'll see on page three
line four that Das is going to provide
um
quarterly reports to this legislative
parking garage oversight Commission
so that's what the amendment does we
sought to really build in more oversight
to the project and I hope that the
committee will support the amendment
can we adopt the amendment by a show of
hands representative Hewitt Mr chairman
on my copy of the uh the sheet here I
note that the amendment number is zero
four two one H yes I I apologize I had
the McGuire Amendment and it's so
seamless in our division I read the
wrong number
so I want to clarify that the motion
that I am moving is zero four two one H
doesn't miss a thing
okay can I do this by a show of hands
all in favor of adopting Amendment
any opposed
okay
24-1
all right
Paul
all right the motion that representative
Abel make now makes is
um Mr chairman I'd like to move ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 384.
all second second by representative
Sweeney or Campbell you're all on
the clerk will call the role on ought to
pass as amended by 421 on House Bill
384.
I'm sorry
um
this is
got it
o2pa all right so we all know
all right representative erf yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representer Mooney
yes
represent a hole no
representative Sweeney yes
representative popovichi mower yes
representative norgren yes there's an
unleashment yes
yes
representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
Arizona Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
yes representative yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
Arizona Wilder yeah
Mr chairman the vote is 22-3 in favor
we have adopted uh House Bill 384 as
amended by
421 representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman so next on our
agenda here's 506. it's relative to the
construction of a rail chilled box
tunnel in Dairy this was quite a lively
discussion so I like to turn this over
to representative McGuire
and thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
move in expedient to legislate on House
here a second
further discussion would you like me to
explain please all right so um this is a
bill uh brought To Us by representative
Pearson who I see in the room and he
made a fairly strong case for this this
is um there's there's a very uh High
expensive construction on ion-93 EX
there's a brand new exit exit 4A it's a
construction is I think at this time
over 125 million dollars worth and in
their original design they they had a
crossing for a rail trail that would go
through a tunnel under the Connector
Road and
um as the design progressed D.O.T
changed the design to have both the
surface
Crossing as well as a kind of a
circuitous second crossing under a
bridge that was nearby and
um so we we had a lot a testimony on
this it was very active but at the end
of the day our division decided not to
second guess Dot's actions which seemed
to us to be reasonable and also not to
add any kind of potential delays to such
motion before us is inexperienced
legislative bill 506.
representative Griffin
I'd like to add one thing to Mr
McGuire's comments a second there is an
existing contract between Dot
and the town
and this would put us in the middle of
that
situation which would be a bad thing I
believe
see another hand over there
representative papovichi Muller
first I would like to thank division one
for the uh
amount of work they put into this it is
deeply appreciated and my community
members who got involved really really
are grateful for all the time and effort
that you put in second I would like to
note that um
I would normally vote no on this ideal
but this is the original version of the
bill which includes the criminal
penalties and all that and uh
even though I would support the
substance of the bill I will be unable
to support that particular language so
I'll be unable to you know do that but I
wanted to clarify thank you
further discussion
uh yes Mr chairman the bill was actually
amended we took that language out of why
we don't have a corrected copy I'm not
sure but just so the record is clear we
did take that punishing language out
thank you it is the original language
here
you still have your light on
representative papovich
turn your mic up there you go clerk will
call a role on the motion of itl house
bill 506.
thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
McGuire yes
Arizona Petrie votes yes representative
Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
representative hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative Mueller no
representative Auburn yeah
yeah there's General leishman yes
yes
representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes version of
evil yes representative tolorski
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 22-3 in favor
of the Ito
thank you we have itl House Bill 506
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman next we have House
Bill 555
appropriating state general fund Surplus
towards a retirement system
representative McGuire and thank you Mr
chairman I vote I I move
ought to pass on the house bill 555.
is there a second
representing whole seconds
so may I speak yes so this one is a
policy straight policy bill that has no
Financial impact but it's about our
policy in finance so what it says is
that if at such time the amount in the
rainy day fund is equal to 10 percent of
the biennial amount of the general fund
which today would be something like 300
plus million dollars
then any further surpluses
75 percent of them would go to pay off
the unfunded liability of the retirement
system
so it's a it would only take effect if
um
the the general fund has a very adequate
cushion or the rainy day fund has a very
adequate cushion and such and then we
would start move start paying off our
debts in the form of the unfunded
liability
um
we're not there yet but should we get
there I think this is a very very good
idea
seeing none that the clerk will call a
role on ought to pass on House Bill 555.
thank you Mr chairman representative yes
president McGuire yes representative
Petrie votes yes representative Emrick
yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
it was in a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbells yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner
president norgren yeah
representative Leachman yes president
Buco yes
representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes Arizona evil yes
representative tolorski yes
representative again Phillips yes
there's gonna Stringham yes
original water
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 in favor
um Mr chairman may I suggest that this
go on consent because I don't think it
actually there's no dollar amount
involved
any objection to this bill going on
consent seeing none yes we can put it on
consent
thank you for division one we'll move on
to division two representative emmerich
thank you thank you Mr chairman our
first bill is House Bill 129 and we have
uh Amendment 0933
for consideration
uh
the amendment
basically modifies the original bill
that was submitted and also the original
some of the original language it was in
the RSA
do you have a copy of the amendment uh
in this amendment packet and basically
what the amendment does
it takes the bathroom installation
language out of the original RSA and
just says what made it made available
leaving it up to the school district on
where they're going to how they're going
to handle this or the school
it changes girls to menstruating student
in order to resolve future complications
the money has been deleted this is a
free free of charge
the 28-a suggestion was uh negated
because we actually give that the
schools over a billion dollars a year
and we figure hygiene products could be
covered by that
um
and I believe that's it for the
amendment
second
it was second by representative Petrie
any objection to adopting it by a show
of hands
seeing none all in favor of adopting
opposed
two three
Earth whole
and being
okay Mr chairman I would move HB 129 as
amended
is there a second
I check it out okay
Motion in a second
ought to pass as amended by 933 on House
Bill 129.
is there any further discussion seeing
none uh representative Mooney thank you
Mr chair does the fiscal note change
representative Emrick
well since we took since we took the
money out of the bill
I would assume there wouldn't be a
uh fiscal motor any longer yeah
yeah so so I have a question about that
I as I recall a fiscal note it's been a
while since I looked at it the fiscal
note was meant to reflect the cost of
the current law to the schools did it
not or or was it the fiscal notes
strictly what it would cost the state if
we met our 28a obligations can you can
you remind can you remind me Fiscal note
was calculated based on the original
bills
uh formula formula for financing current
costs and retroactive payments thank you
some previous cases have gone to the
Supreme Court on 28a issues for schools
and the decisions I recall were you're
already getting a billion dollars
find the money in that
so that was the way that it was decided
in the Supreme Court it isn't like
you're going to Nickel Dime us for every
last thousand dollars when you're
already getting a billion
so
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
on House Bill 129 as amended by zero
nine three three h
thank you Mr chairman the mission is not
to pass as amended
representative erf yes
president McGuire yes there's no Petri
vote Yes representative Emrick yes
represent Griffin yes representative
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
president Bean
representative hole no
representative Sweeney yes
version of cameras no
yes
representative Waller
representative norgren yes
Arizona leishman yes
original Buco yes
representative uh grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
version of Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes
yes representative
yes
and Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
and representative Weiler
yes
22 yeah it's 22-3 huh
I can't read my own right and sorry Mr
chairman 22-3
thank you could I possibly suggest going
consent since we took the money out
yes we will any objection to it going on
consent
it will go on consent
oh I skipped 207 that's an ought to pass
I'm falling apart here
HB 207 relative to school districts
receiving unanticipated funds very
straightforward bill it was ought to
pass eight to zero what it does is it
takes the threshold for a public hearing
for un uh unexpected funds from five
thousand dollars to twenty thousand
dollars very straightforward
okay Motion in a second ought to pass on
House Bill 207 is there any further
discussion
seeing none the clerical called a role
on the motion of ought to pass on House
two that's 207 right I'm sorry what did
I say 207 thank you 2-0
yeah we're catching something up here
all right uh thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Earth yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petrie votes
yes representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes
yes representative hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative mower yes
representative Waller
representative yes
representative leishman yes Arizona Buco
yes
representative grassy
representative Hewitt yes
Heath yes
there's another Murray yes
there's no evil
yes representative yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative water yes Mr chairman of
vote is 25 to zero in in the affirmative
thank you representative Emrick thank
you Mr chairman next HB 332 which is
relative to school building Aid we voted
eight to zero to retain this bill Mr
consideration on the budget Mr chairman
representative hole is on the HB 207
um without objection I don't believe it
spends any money it just gives
permission any objection to going on
consent
that's what school is a motion okay the
clerk will call the roll on retain for
thank you Mr chairman representative URF
yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
represent hole
yes
yes version Sweeney
there's no cameras yes
version of Pop of 80 Mueller
yes
representative Waller
was that an ogre yes
there's no leishman yes
representative bucco yes
representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
version of Heath yes
there's no Murray yes
version of evil yes representative
tolorski yes
president haken Phillips yes
we're gonna string them
yes
version of water yes Mr chairman of vote
is 25-0 in affirmative
motion passes
representative Emrick
thank you Mr chairman next is House Bill
468 this is making an approach
appropriation for the Department of
Education to re-codify uh their existing
laws uh we're retaining this one while
we're doing some homework because the
original bill was for a hundred thousand
dollars and you've seen the size of the
education laws they're never going to
get done for a hundred thousand dollars
but we have no idea what the budget so
working with OLS
give us some idea so we might be able to
work this into the budget but for now
we'd like to retain this
the vote was eight to zero
second
saying none the clerical call a role to
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes
representative McGuire yes
representative
Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes president
representative hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Waller
there's a representative norgren yes
representative Leachman yes
yes representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative Abel yes
representative tolorski yes
representative Phillips yes
you're gonna Stringham
yes
there's no wire yes Mr chairman of old
uh moving on representative 541 uh
representative emmerich thank you Mr Mr
chairman uh this is relative to school
building a aid and grants making a pro
appropriation there for as in all of
these bills we are voted eight to zero
to retained and discuss as part of the
budget
further discussion
the motion to retain house bill 541.
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
on retain for house bill 541.
thank you Mr chairman representative yes
original McGuire yes representative
Petrie volt yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
representative hole yes representative
Kim uh
Sweeney yes trick myself
representative Campbell's yes
yes
representative Wallner
Richard representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
yes
representative uh grassy
representative Hewitt yes
Arizona Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative uh evil yes
yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes Mr chairman of
vote is 25-0
in new firmative we have voted to retain
House Bill 541 representative Emrick
thank you Mr chairman House Bill 546 is
relative to the school building a
program as in other of these uh
Educational Funding bills we are voted
to retain eight to zero
second
further discussion Henry the motion to
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
president Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes represent
a bean
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative
yes Reverend popovichi Mueller yes
representative norgren yes president
Leachman yes
representative bucco yes
representative grassy yes
representative you would yes
Arizona Heath yes representative Murray
yes
Arizona tolersky yes
president haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
George
we have voted to retain House Bill 546
moving on to division three
representative Edwards
um Mr chair division three considered
House Bill 527 relative to Medicaid
reimbursement rates for certain assisted
living facilities we voted nine to
nothing to retain it so that we could
consider it as part of the budget effort
uh the the basic issue that we observed
was it was uh very narrowly defined and
perhaps too narrowly when we think we
need to take a broader look at it
foreign
further discussion that's your bill
on the motion to retain House Bill 527
thank you Miss Sharon
person of Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie voltius
representative uh Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards
yes representative Bean
yeah it was in a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes Arizona Campbell yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Waller
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative bucco yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hewitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
version of evil yes
was that was that a yes
representative tolorski yes
representative Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
representative Edwards
uh Mr chair
um I would move to reconsider HB 49
that's a joke by the way little levity
thank you I don't want to hear anything
I saw you representative Heath grabbing
something to throw uh We've uh we've
discussed HP 49 and I think we've come
just remember the Ides of March is upon
us
no this was
it it did come out ought to pass as
amended with the uh
0892 Amendment and uh somebody needs to
okay our earlier vote on the amendment
was
21 to 4 and on the ought to pass as
amended was 23 to 2. will the committee
accept that Vote or do you want to do it
again
anybody wanna
go through that again Mr chairman I
thought
um
representative Edwards said he was
joking and then we moved on and had a
private side conversation I missed
okay then what is the chairman asking us
to do
so earlier this a couple hour an hour no
about an hour ago
we voted on several amendments the one
we adopted
was zero eight nine two by a vote of
21 to 4.
and then we moved to ought to pass as
amended by that Amendment then the vote
was
23 to 2.
that was about
three o'clock or so yep
so does anybody wish to do another roll
call on this I am so tired of this bill
[Laughter]
just the question uh did that end up
and this and another rule we usually
follow if there's money in a bill it
doesn't go on consent unless it's itl we
see a lot of FN bills on consent with an
Ito that's fine
but if there's money to be spent it's
not good to have it on the consent
calendar
does anybody
wish to have any further roll call on
ought to pass as amended House Bill 49
by Amendment 0892
good
thank you very much
now tomorrow the
representative walner I think you're
getting ready to do just what I was
going to ask you could you kind of
outline for us what we have for the next
couple of weeks what our schedule is
going to be
what our deadlines are particularly
we have deadlines at the end of March
we'll probably go before
um
let's see Mr Ripple or Mr landrigan can
tell us when we have to come before the
I think it might be on Thursday the 30th
good afternoon good afternoon
so I'm gonna work starting from today so
looking into next week we have a couple
house session days the 22nd 23rd we do
have session tomorrow as well the 23rd
was the day that we've been kind of
holding as the division deadline
so we're hoping everything is decided at
the division level by that day that will
give us that weekend to put together the
detail changes the packages all the
Amendments for that following week which
is Monday the 27th
those days is when will exec House Bill
one and two here from the division
shares do the presentations of the
divisions recommendations as well as
boy 20 30 however many more bills that
the committee still has we'll have to
exec that week
jumping forward after the final data
report the budget will be the 30th
jumping forward that following week
there would be a House briefing to uh
the finance committee would brief the
house on the House pass budget excuse me
the house finance pass budget
I don't know the exact date for that
usually as either that Monday or Tuesday
so the third or the fourth and I don't
think that's been scheduled yet
the third or fourth of April April yes
Okay so we've we've got some time
um
in in divisions can you brief us on the
plan that you have
we will probably meet again to exec some
some more bills that we still have
before us I believe
representative leishman do you want to
spell out your plans sure Mr chairman
we're just about done with meeting with
everyone we've uh I would say about
85 or 90 done with our work
we should have no trouble meeting the
deadline of having everything ready for
presentation
by the 23rd do you have anything
immediately ahead that you want to
discuss
we do have a couple of bills that are
holding us up on retirement that's
pretty much our only concern House Bill
463 436.
and 571 is that the right one
other than that uh we'll have about 20
bills coming to the full committee and
also 250. yeah and I'd like to May oh
sure yeah so um this Friday at one
o'clock is when we're going to have the
presentation from the Edna committee to
our division on all of the licensing
Provisions in House Bill 2 currently
greater than 50 percent of the pages uh
but some a lot of those will go away so
um but we'll get all the details from
them uh Friday at one if anyone wants to
join us
one o'clock thank you I'll try and make
that
division two
well as soon as we break from this
session we are going to reconvene in
division two room today for about an
hour
uh LBA has some additional information
for us and then we we convene again uh
Friday morning at 10 for the day
thank you and represent representative
Edwards for division three
I think we're getting pretty close we
have a lot of discussion it hurt not
having uh yesterday's work day
um but I I I think we're going to end up
making all the deadlines anyways I don't
think we're going to be in agreement but
we'll be done because we'll be out of
time
representative Hull thank you Mr chair
the schedule that was given to us for
the calendar is there a way to get that
as a document so those of us who are
visual can look at it and know when we
yeah let's I think it'll all go in the
calendar
um representative yes there's also
um on the on the cork board here in
Janet's office is a is a calendar which
you can pull down and copy and put back
so
foreign
I appreciate all your patience for the
long public hearing we had it was
shorter than many that some of us have
sat through
I think I I had one for 10 hours some
years ago
this was a little under four I think
that was pretty good and I appreciated
the fact you all listened and took any
notes you wanted to and we'll be
bringing those up some of the things as
you look at those sections of the budget
it's not uncommon for us to have
everybody that comes to us wanting to
spend more money that's usually the way
I think one time somebody came and said
I think you should cut the budget
but
I appreciate the fact you were all there
and and you were all patient and you all
listened and attentively and I think
that's what the public appreciates I've
got to congratulate Joe who said time
and nobody argued that was also very
uncommon
because normally we'd say time and
they'd say I just got two more pages or
something like that and then I'd have to
say please wrap it up in about three
sentences and sometimes I was successful
and then we also had to brief the
sergeant arms staff and they would start
moving slowly up the aisle to take the
person out but we're never allowed to
grab them I'll put hands on them but
some of them finally took the hint that
okay you've said enough and especially I
was glad that some people appreciated
the fact I was able to not everybody put
who they were speaking for but when they
put what group they were speaking for I
could group them together and then say
okay those are the three you're all
talking about the same thing you don't
need to say the same thing just if you
agree or if there's something to add
that was successful saved us probably 10
or 15 minutes throughout the night so we
finished in less than four hours which
is somewhat of a record so I appreciate
all the patience you had sorry I didn't
provide a meal I was thinking if if it
was going to go real late I'd have to
order out but it went pretty well and I
appreciate the attendance of this
committee and the fact that you're all
willing to work so hard on this because
the budget is a challenge and it's game
it came to us this is one of the more
challenging times on this budget two
years ago we found that it was the
governor's budget was 70 million more
than what ways and means told us this
time Ways and Means was two weeks late
and then told us they were 85 million
over what they said we could spend so
that left us right away trying to do
cuts and then when we had all those
bills
52 of them all wanting to spend more
money it's another challenge so I
appreciate the fact you've all studied
very hard and tried to figure out a way
to make it all work because that's what
we have to do that's why we're here on
the finance committee that's why some of
us come back year after year to do this
because it is an intellectual challenge
that keeps us all on our toes and there
are ways we discover that yes we can do
this and it still looks good and maybe
the house will will accept it one of the
things that shocked me in the past I
looked at what was called a tax
expenditure limitation which I heard of
in 2000 from people in Colorado they
passed the taxpayers Bill of Rights in
it it said that a budget cannot increase
over the past budget by more than
the rate of inflation plus the
population increase
so I've asked LBA tell me what that is
here's the surprise in the two years
prior to this budget
inflation was 12.7 percent
population increase was one and a half
percent
those add up to over 14 percent
I don't think any of us want to increase
a budget 14 plus we don't have the
revenue
the governor's budget was well short of
that and our budget will be even a
little shorter
so
if you have talks with any of the other
members who might be thinking oh I don't
know if I want to vote for this inform
them of the fact that what are you going
to do with 12 and a half percent or
twelve point seven percent inflation
over the previous two years we've had
discussions about the
contract that the governor signed
and I think we heard in in division one
from administrative Services it's been
signed you can't do anything about it
it's ten percent the first year two
percent the second year which
now we discover that's that's pretty
much what inflation's been so
you've got to admit that and and kind of
stick with what we've been handed
and still try to find other ways to
spend
um some people have said Gee do we need
all these employees what we've
discovered through the years is is
there's some more efficiency in in
government
at one point there were a lot of people
filling out a form handing it to someone
else to fill it out a little differently
handing it to somebody else now we have
information technology that you can fill
it out once and it gets populated
wherever it needs to be I am still
waiting
and for about now
20 years
for the business one stop
which we've talked about some of us have
heard about it for year after year after
year
some years ago my daughter opened a ice
cream stand and I said ice cream shop
and I said how'd that business One Stop
work she said what are you talking about
I said didn't you just fill out one form
you're crazy
I had to go
three places
on Health and Human Services
two three places on
the Department of Revenue Administration
one place on uh dot entrances and exits
and one place where the uh Secretary of
State to okay the name of the business
and see that it wasn't duplicated
somewhere else so
I am told
by uh one of the people that works on
that sort of thing at the governor's
office that now they have put out a
contract for business one stop
now I think the reason it was
it was uh slow walked all these 20 years
is because oh we don't want to lay out
this this receptionist we don't lay her
off but we don't lay off this person
that passes out the the uh the form so
that may save us a few jobs and and
these efficiencies should continue we've
got um
you know information technology working
on that sort of thing and we will
encourage them when they come into us to
keep it up
because that has been what's made um
manufacturing and everything else in
this country far more efficient so look
for those things and if they say another
thing I've discovered is oh we've got a
lot of vacancies we've got a lot of
vacancies but when I asked the treasurer
for account of the paychecks
it wasn't that short of what it had been
in the past
so keep an eye on that I think it's
available to us the number of checks
that go out and I think it's by by
department so
if they come in and say we need a lot
more people and you say well you've got
the same number you've had for years and
you should be getting more efficient
every year so why do you need so many
people so look at those things in the
next week if you're going Page by Page
through the through the budget of course
as always the general fund pages are the
ones we have to pay the most attention
to there are many things that are funded
by their own sources like Banking and
insurance and we hope the highway fund
will will keep the Department of
Transportation going well
so maybe we don't have to put as much
general fund in there fish and game
called me the other day to say that
you know this 10 pay raise
they have their own funds they get them
through selling the licenses
and they did have a great year a couple
years ago when everybody was
couldn't go anywhere because of kovitz
so they all went hunting and then
fishing or whatever and so they had a
very good year but it's it hasn't been
as as much since so they're starting to
whittle away at that Surplus they had
they didn't think they could afford to
give the pay raise
the 10 pay raise to all the employees
they have and they said the governor
promised them that it would come out of
General funds so division two will be
working on that and I know
um
Mickey will be involved taking a look at
that and see if it in fact is in the
fish and game budget that that pay raise
is there
and so those those are the kind of
little knit noise that we've got to
worry about I was very unimpressed with
hb2 and all the things that went in
there without in my mind very clear
thought when you say we don't need
surveyor licenses anymore and those of
us that have been on a planning board or
dealt with the registered Deeds they're
damn well better be licensed surveyor
stamp and license on that plan and name
so why do you think you can just easily
say oh we don't need licenses for
surveyors and that and similar
throughout that oplc piece but we will
be hearing more from
executive departments and administration
which will be helpful on what they
consider that and a lot of those things
are like one particular oh we never get
any complaints about them so why do they
need a license
foreign
yeah
yeah so you know oh if we don't have any
complaints so we'd have to take your
license away why do they need a license
well because somewhere is in the law
some places in the law it might mention
it and if you haven't looked all those
places up
then and some of it might be in in town
ordinances I know a lot of that stuff on
like the surveyor's license was in my
town ordinance and and we'd have to look
at that at planning boards so
a lot of little places we learn as we go
uh it's it's it's a great learning
experience for an old man like me that
new things keep popping up give me a few
more brain cells working so
did you have any more comments
Vice chair does anybody plan to write a
minority report for those that had
minorities
no okay
if so we need to have it marked then we
need to have it
in the next few hours or a few few
minutes a few minutes
don't make uh don't make Janice stay
late and Hound you for it
I know that uh representative McGuire
has written most of them so
congratulations and he's got them
already thank you all for your attention
thank you all for your patience uh I
guess division two is going to meet or
any of the other divisions going to meet
not one not three division three 9 30
Friday
we're going to have it we're going to
start at nine o'clock for the session
tomorrow nine o'clock
so we'll try to cover a lot of bills